and we
are live welcome to the last word with
laura cognito and ibontis
fresh on that friday campfire morning
how are we doing sir we've got
somebody special today what's going on
today yeah we got a great friend of the
show it's been a pretty good week it's a
light week for 12 but we definitely got
plenty to talk about with this awesome
gentleman so
uh we're gonna flip it old school here
we're going back to you sir let's bring
this man in
no doubt welcome to the last word
episode number 114
it's another glorious friday we're back
in front of the campfire for some more
lunar shooter discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest so we gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord who's not
only a close friend to the campfire and
the realm of the iop
but whose positivity within the destiny
community and unmatched passion for our
favorite bungie franchise
is clearly his forte
introducing the creator and host of the
gaming forte youtube and twitch channels
and a panelist for the scumcast and brat
podcast
our favorite nautical hunter
and the guardian who will always co-sign
wrath of the machine as his top rate and
flawlessly pump stopping three win
on less foes and trials oh lord
live from michigan and making his long
overdue debut at the campfire of the
last
word my man lord gaming forte how you
doing sir
man oh man what's up man let's let's i'm
gonna put this i'm trying to compare
this to the one on iop
and then you outdid yourself so there we
go
what a iop was good i was i was
wondering if um
e was good i was like who's gonna do
this today oh it had
it had to be cognito this morning it had
to be cognito
nev i was sitting there i actually went
back and listened to
um episode i forget what episode it was
but it was march 22nd with slo-mo on and
i was like
i gotta see who he gives the better
intro to
i was like
because the last time uh we did this uh
slow mo
me and slobo both did iop at the same
time yes
so it was so it was like oh i got to see
who
um intro so i i will say i
i i beat him yes yes here we go
i had so much information with you so i
it was about picking what i wanted to
talk about
so it's just like all right what i want
to tell about what i want to tease what
i want to have fun with what i want to
celebrate him with you know
rest in peace nautical yes rest in peace
no articles you know
that's why i had to get that because i
you know listen
this is the joke y'all for the chat who
doesn't know you know forte he helps us
out tremendously
both of our clans he helps he bounces
out he helps me out i love podcasts
and like we know him as gaming forte on
twitter
and all these other things but the world
i mean in
in destiny his profile is nautical so
when we i would play with him it would
just bother me because i didn't want to
like for people who don't know him and
wearing a fireteam i gotta say daughter
i'm like that's not his name though he's
there he's forte to me you know what's
that kind of thing so it was
salute to you for for actually merging
the whole lord gave attack thing yeah i
did but for
the fact that i had to put it on my
twitter because people was like why'd
you change it and
all this other stuff and i put up there
i was like man it's a i had to do
something because people was getting
i got tired of answering different
questions about
who's this person who's that person and
if anybody didn't know the reason it was
nautical is because i went to school for
marine biology
cool so my love of the water nautical
all made sense so i was one of those
gamer tags that actually
had a purpose behind it so i still i
still have it um shout out to randolph
thor he made
um his video showed me how to actually
still preserve
my original nautical i had to make a
separate account and wow
the moment i the moment i switched
everything over to gaming forte
i made a separate account that picked up
the nautical name so
i can go back and get it at any time i
just gotta pay the ten dollars if i want
to go back if you're watching
look at you copyright protection look at
him oh yeah he's got it just like
branded i mean we got a brand we got to
protect it right just like the redskins
you know
somebody oh oh oh my lord are we jumping
we're doing that this morning all right
we going early we're going in we go
there's a look man obviously we got a
lot of stuff a lot of questions i'm
gonna let you set off the questioning
you know what i'm saying because uh we
know you but you know a lot of the world
don't know who the forte is man so
what questions we got for the for the
man the legendary hunter here
yeah uh i'm just gonna start with the
old school stuff just because i liked
how uh how long you've been gaming so
we've all been gaming for a little while
but um yeah like what was the history in
gaming for you just a little brief like
how long has it been
and then also just some top top games
through the
through the history of all gaming we
know destiny's obviously in there but
some other ones that you know some high
ones between uh
the older generations what is would have
been some loves oh man so
like i said it's atari 2600 is where it
all started at and the funny thing is i
can't remember
one game i played on that system because
my one memory
of having that system was um i got it
when i was
eight and it was my first system but i
came across it in a funny way because it
was a christmas gift
and this is when parents didn't know how
to hide their gifts very well
we had a we we had a attic and um
shout out to houses that have addicts
but uh had an
addict so she put like a big trash bag
on the stairs
going up to the attic because we never
used to go up there and i just happened
to go off that's like what's in this
giant
bag that's sitting on the stairs so of
course i rambled through this at eight
years old and i saw ooh
atari 2600 act like i didn't see it so
i will always remember even though i
remember none of the games i played on
it because
it was like it was like very blurry back
then because i wasn't i was into like
soccer baseball i was i did everything
when i was younger back then
and uh so i don't remember exactly i
played up but that was the first system
i had
but um it all started with really nes
nes was um the first system that i
truly realized that this hobby
was more than just a hobby it was like
the point where your friends would be
outside and he's like nah man i'm in
here playing
mega man or something man it's like oh
you two are friends it was like mega man
2 and 3. dr wily's castle theme for me
like i still go pull that thing up on
spotify every now and then wow
like yes man mega man
mega man's one of those games i think
that trained us for like some of the
stuff we face now
because i like the dark souls of its
time
mega man was the dark souls like it was
evil if you like when you go back
because i forgot the mega man collection
wow i don't know when it came out more
recently and it has the save states in
there and it's so easy to just like
i'm going to save right here before this
crappy jump be like nope die die die
die and it's like as opposed to you get
two lives and you start the whole damn
level over again and it's just like
oh no mega man's mega man's a dark souls
like patience and gaming trainer that's
what that is absolutely
absolutely yeah anyway back to where you
were sorry i just had no i
no well dude i would never stop anybody
when they talk about mega man
that that game was um very influential
of the things that i started lacking i
mean to the point where
i did a flawless run of that whole game
when i was probably like 14.
i literally stayed up like probably 18
19 hours you know trying to do this run
and i i finally got it like
i remember it was like 1 30 in the
morning when i got
in my brother my brother's like three
years younger to me he's sitting next to
me like
you know he wants me to get it but he's
sitting up there like yo
yo you gonna mess up you gonna mess up
i'm like literally jumping on the um
on the platforms with the dragon and
stuff trying to take the dragon off he's
like no he's like you're gonna mess up
you gonna be
i'll say leave me alone it was epic
so i was your first flawless raider
achievement before
just my very first night slo solo follow
us right there
talking about those writers yeah yeah
and then uh that took me into games like
contra doing stuff and that you know
beating the game without the 30-man code
oh slow solutions absolutely that
oh yeah yeah the konami code the code
yeah you always wondered like i do know
that the uh
magazines print that stuff but the fact
that how
information got around yes that young is
think about
incredible incredible no social media
yeah no social media
how do people know that they had to
stick their cartridge in just a little
bit just to make the click to make sure
that their game
worked like how do you how do you
demonstrate that
in a paragraph yes it's a good point
that's a good point so i always wondered
that but it's like you know people just
word of mouth just flies when it comes
to video games so
uh yeah so nes was was the was the jam
um um then after that it went straight
into
of course it went to snes snes first
time that you saw uh
that's when i got into sports games and
stuff with madden and everything
yes yes yes yep that's when madden went
to um not having uh i believe that's the
year that it went to not having to win
the passing windows the end
so yeah that jumped oh actually i take
that back that's not when it has that's
when
i was like i played tecmo bowl so i
think i'm sports was earlier
you talking about bo jackson's simulator
that's like that
super tech mobility
i think bill jackson definitely was tops
in that game yeah bo jackson was
unstoppable like he was ridiculous
yeah then you go over to sega and get uh
joe montana sports talk where you
actually had an announcement
yeah first time and voice voice yeah
yeah and then um
i remember i got super into live when uh
the year before allen iverson went to
the nba that's when they had the whole
creative character thing was a huge
thing
and nobody had a conscience of making
their characters like i'm gonna make
this character balanced no i'm just
gonna make everything 99 overall
i mean yeah that's that's what you're
gonna do that's what everybody did it
was like well
i guess everybody's players are gonna be
and then you literally will have legit
games against people with characters
that are 99 overall like you're really
gonna miss a shot
ridiculous uh those days yeah so but
you know like i said that's where the
love started at but did
it like the fire got lit
when xbox came out when
uh even before xbox it was the game
called halo
and uh bungie showed it off at mac world
and we were like it's gonna be on pc and
i was like oh that's fine i don't care
cause you know i don't
even then i didn't have like this cons
this thing like i have to have
this one console i i wasn't strictly
nintendo
genesis or anything like that i was like
wherever the games are gonna be there
yeah
so they were like oh it's gonna be on pc
and i'm like
cool so i went out and bought a voodoo
500 because it was
literally a voodoo 500 bro because it
was this
it was the card that was promoted with
debt with uh i would say destiny with uh
halo on the hill on the back of it and
this is when halo was an rts
at that point yeah they didn't change it
over to a first person shooter
yes with the best buyers spent 200 and
something bucks on this graphics card
as a what was i like what 17
16 17 and um bought that
and i was like cool it did literally six
months later microsoft bought bungie
and made it a first party exclusive and
they said oh and on top of that we have
this system called xbox coming out
so oh my so all my my my thoughts and
everything i was like well i'm sitting
with this graphics card so
i just started playing a bunch of pc
games like star wars armada
and black and white the god games
the amount of time i put into games like
got like
black and white is ridiculous like
staying up to like five o'clock in the
morning
wow trying to trying to help this
civilization live
or pick them up and just throw them yeah
yes you can just literally throw people
so
the hand of literally the hand of god
yeah shout out to my brother
oh man it was it yes it was it was
beautiful you got the the creatures
walking around
i was like jesus christ this is crazy
but then um
yeah so when um xbox announced that they
were
mm-hmm yeah so when xbox uh announced
that they were doing the system
i was all in 100 i i went to
um it wasn't called fed it was basically
their launch party i went to
um new york to actually get a part of it
yes
i was there i was there bro i was there
for the original og joint
because you know that's in new york i
was in new york yeah bill gates the rock
was there yeah
it was like like literally the people a
lot of people want to realize why i have
that such a tied xbox is that
um one they launched the og in new york
in new york two
it's my birthday november 15 is when
that's when it launched
so it was like yo i gotta have this
system now and then obviously the bungee
tie
with hey look so it all kind of makes
sense for my love for xbox and bungie
and
and all that stuff it literally all came
together at that that's crazy
yo i didn't know you we were in the sick
wow shout out to the build restaurant
he's new york too so that was a big
thing for new york city like
you know you know they launched the xbox
it was huge
and it was such a spectacle they had all
the stars come out
you know for their console that's crazy
you were there wow microsoft has the
money they're like
we gotta yeah we're new we gotta we
gotta get some slubs in here you gotta
get some people in here
yeah man my um my mom is a traveling
nurse so she was uh
when she worked on strikes and stuff so
they were it was like hospitals there
were striking at the point
so she was working there so it like made
it super easy to just go to new york and
like stay with her we were live me and
my brother like i was 18
19 at that time my brother was like 16
so we were staying at the house while
you know we were kings living
living at home no parent so
so she was like oh i was we were talking
to her about the
xbox stuff and she's like oh yeah i
heard about that that's going to be
literally downtown and stuff and she was
like if y'all want to come
y'all can just stay in the hotel with me
so i didn't have to pay for a hotel oh
man there you go
so it it literally just worked itself
out i drunk way too much surge
shout out to sir shout out to surge they
were giving those out like crazy he's
giving those things out like water at
that thing yes that's the original
advanced gg
well yeah that's that's yeah the
original like red bull
rock star yeah yeah yeah get your heart
rate up crazy
yeah jesus is terrible
yeah so that was cool met all met a lot
of cool people from xbox
back then and um yeah i probably walked
right by you didn't even know
bro we probably didn't you know we were
just it was space how crazy is that
that's great
it was crazy down there and then
everything is like history from there i
mean
after halo literally changed the
opinions of
what a first person shooter on the
console was in fact you know before
before that it was like this isn't going
to work
on a rifle right at all you know and
then holding that giant duke controller
shout out to that thing it's like how do
we even play with that controller
yeah shout out to the dude shout out to
the duke shout out to the s
the readers that that thing
that thing was beautiful um
yeah the duke man and then um everything
just
literally just kept going up from there
when it you know
xbox live came out a year later you
never realize
how much you wanted to just have
competition with people
yes until xbox live came out i was there
day one
79.99 went to the mall to go buy the
the kit with the headset the little
wireless receiver
that you can get on the back of the 360
too oh my god
yeah it was yeah it would have got all
that and then um
and then halo was always a staple but um
i will tell you where competitive like
shout out to the competitive side of
things
yeah ghost recon oh
like if i if i had to like say outside
of halo my
favorite game on the original xbox was
ghost
guy oh yeah original original the
original the original graw
and now i had xbox live yeah i was blown
away just being able to talk to people
and play that game at the same time
truly a game
game changer absolutely i don't know if
you guys know him but uh cdn the third
everybody probably knows him he streams
a lot on different things he he streams
um
uh fortnite pubg everything
uh that's the man that i always uh he's
huge now
but that dude is the goo that got me
into competitive like
to the point where we would be running
i was at a a huge clan back then and he
would literally show me how to do
drop shots how to look and survey maps
and stuff
how to be able to move and get and get
in and out of different areas of games
or different
engagements and stuff and uh playing
tournaments i got to the point where
um i would do um
game battles when it was when the
website where you would go there and
just do
clan stuff i would literally set
tournaments up for ghost recon and
everything for people in there i did a
huge solo tournament that we um
that we did in there uh so that's when
the competitive fire
literally started burning and then halo
2 came out that it was it was
it was history after that so two and
three or so special
yeah so yeah that's tremendous
the history win i mean of course there's
other systems the playstation came up
after that because
shout out to them once they showed
madden with stadium lights it was over
it was over yeah i remember that i
remember how big the polygons was i was
going crazy
i remember that it was it was definitely
changing shout out to sony making
everybody have to buy
oh not sony i go say sony shout out to
best buy can i work that best buy there
literally in order to buy a playstation
2 you had to buy
three items with it yes yes you
had to buy three items with it they made
you you buy the system you had
to buy a controller or two controllers
in the game
or the memory card which most people was
going to do it was because you had to
have memory cards
i literally that was the first time i
did an overnight for a system
which was probably the most incredible
overnight i ever did uh
shout out to all those people we got
they was having peace it was like
six seven hundred people outside the
store jesus
i got i got my playstation at eight
o'clock in the morning
and had to be back to work at 11 o'clock
that afternoon
that same morning so i literally went
home just to hook my system up
play one game against my brother and go
back to work she's
yo this man's a legend right he talking
real gamer
talk tremendous tremendous history
brother like
you know we go on it all but i gotta ask
you bro yeah i got that
so you know the reason why we're here at
the campfire
you have this uh we all you already have
this this
infatuation this certain game and
one thing i always give you credit is
like being a destiny fan is sometimes
not the easiest thing
because it's like we kind of get
attacked why are we playing this damn
game
you know whatever whatever or bungie's
ripping you off all the stuff that your
abuse you get
as a desi fan but it's always that those
those few people that you can count on
to hold you down and that's my man forte
you have always been a staunch
defender of this game so i gotta ask
from a destiny standpoint how did that
start
when did the love really kick in and
you're like yo this is my game i i don't
care what nothing nobody's saying like
how did that whole thing take place
oh man so as soon as well
as soon as the whole breakup from um
microsoft happened i was like okay
that sucks but because i mean at this
point like this is my favorite franchise
that halo is my favorite franchise so i
was like
all right so it is what it is and the
inklings of them making a new game was
already very apparent because they were
putting stuff
in odst and everything like that so when
we saw the traveler for the first time
in in that game
it was like oh yeah this new thing
they're making
so once they announced destin they
showed it at e3 that year on sony stage
it was a rap i was like yo first of all
i want people to stop doing this fake
call out stuff like
you know the chatter over the thing like
this makes actually no sense just show
the game
i don't care about all these different
people like they like how they do with
rainbow six and they have the ubers
they're so bad yeah oh my god break
break break and like no
stop doing that just show me the game so
um
bungie had did that and fine i
overlooked it because i was like i just
what i'm seeing is pretty incredible you
know when you you look at it now the
tank battle
seems like very minuscule compared to
where destiny is now
but back then seeing people drop into
the game like
seamlessly i was like dude this is crazy
and uh got into the beta love the beta
didn't know that the beta literally was
three quarters of the game
[Music]
[Laughter]
shout out to cosby trolls quarter it's
about a quarter
but yeah a quarter a quarter one
it felt like more than that no because
the cosmodrome was most of the game
it was a lot yeah it was a lot so um
yeah so we did that got into that got it
to the beta
loved that then the game launched and
i'm not gonna lie i told
like you know i my love for destiny
did not happen overnight it was it was a
it was a process it was more of
nothing could fulfill what halo had gave
me
and destiny was the only thing on the
market that could do it and over the
course of time
destiny won out but there was a while
where i was telling my friends my fire
team that's like i don't like this game
this story this story is trash literally
i was like
i was like this story's bad because you
know when you
i always tell people halo was all about
the story
yes because it wasn't it was never about
the multiplayer
it was never about that it was always
the story the foundation kept you
engaged
yes it was the reason you kept playing
the game but you bought halo
for the magical story they gave you
right and
um i went into um i went into destiny
with
that same premise you know thinking that
the same people that have that same
level of story it's gonna be
and yeah it's gonna be there yeah it
wasn't that far so it wasn't there it
wasn't on that level
so yeah the things they had in the game
were cool but
i was in a whole completely different
head space and i just wanted i just
wanted story
like it's completely the opposite of
what i am now i could
it's like you know multiplayer for days
but it's like
it took a while so i told my friends
when halo master chief collection comes
out
i'm out i'm sick
i'm going back home i'm going back to
playing the game that i enjoyed the most
oh it didn't it didn't work
it didn't watch i was like that was a
trash fire upon like turning that thing
on that was
painful to watch right so such a broken
game
so i and this is this goes back to like
i was saying about um
what i was telling um u-cog i was like
you know the first time i beat
vault of glass was in heart mode because
i couldn't
stand that game like my friends were
running it my
original raid team had already picked up
another person and everything
so they were running raids every week i
didn't um
truly jump into the game like fully jump
in until dark below came out
got you once
was the magic moment what was the magic
moment that it's like okay
yo i'm in i'm sticking with this that
like i'm
i'm here i get it the first time i
realized that
i could help people in the game and it
was more
because like once i started
meeting new people like not just the
people i had on my friends list already
um the the friends started growing and
then people just started asking me to do
stuff
run sword for them and um and um crota's
end
and then just knowing that you had you
could have an impact outside of just
playing the game and i was like dude
this game is
this is something this is it's more to
this game than just
the devices that it puts in front of you
it's like yes you
you enjoy the things that's happened i
still get bungee crap
every chest i can about not putting
story in the game
and they're doing a lot better now they
just need to do even more better with
the next dlcs that we see and it looks
like they're heading in that direction
but i think anybody that plays destiny
will always have a love-hate
relationship with this game it just
comes down to
how the game it's like what has the game
done for you lately
right now that's a good right now right
now the game is in a place where it's
like it's not really doing anything for
you because it's like
they extended it and we're waiting for
quest stuff to start coming up so
a lot of people that hate on the game
really um
say well why do you still play that game
well right that's because this game it's
nothing like this game
nothing stings
you know what happens right there's
always a new game that comes out
and it's the destiny and fails but why
why why don't they why don't these games
hold up why does destiny survive
gameplays on slots breaking play
gameplay
one thing gameplay you tell me another
game
well you tell me another first person
first of all every game tries to do it
differently
first of all none of them it's something
more intimate about
that camera being pulled in and you
seeing just that gun
it's something very intimate about that
second of all
there has never been a developer that
can give you even a 30 frame experience
um that even matches anything else in
gaming when it comes to like just the
play of the game
you know when you go into crucible
and the way that the movement is the way
that you
can uh you can literally just out date
people that have the same thing you have
you don't have that in other games like
as much as call of duty is one of the
most popular games in the world
that's more about reflexes where destiny
is all about
yeah you can have a way better shot than
somebody but if you
think you can literally outplay anybody
in this game
um and that even comes down to the uh
the single player experience the single
player here is just unmatched to this
game when it comes to
the levels of enjoyment you can have
there's something for everybody in this
game
literally everybody
it's literally nothing i i truly believe
there's nothing any game can truly do
to take this game down and i heard ebony
said the other week he's like
a lot of games try but no destiny will
never fail
it can't fail at this point it's too too
many people support this game
on a day-to-day basis anytime you look
at
daily engagement numbers 1.1 1.2 1.3
million people play it
every day you tell me you tell me a game
that doesn't annualize itself with a new
release every year that does that
and that's the thing that people don't
realize i mean
we've watched anthem we've watched
division twice
uh i mean you've got something like out
writers coming which potentially looks
fun but
it's like the live service game
of this type is
it they found a special place because
they took the space magic part
and that's one of the reasons for me
like division never sticks long run
stuff like survival is cool but like if
you even they're raid it's still like
down to earth so the mechanics can only
be like shoot a vent on a box over here
and i know that's like dumbing it down
when they're on the airfield and stuff
but it's different than
even some of the mechanics we have now
of like standing in light and dark and
dealing with these things in the
dungeons and you've got
you know garden of salvation with all
these
when you go sci-fi when you go fantasy
you have a chance to get with so many
more different mechanics and then as you
said too when it comes to the pvp side
of things
the most skilled people that i probably
watch in this game are
they shoot well no question shroud
shoots well
ninja can shoot well they there's a lot
who can shoot well lupo like
the big names shoot well but the ones
that i watch in this one
are impressive and that's kind of why
fortnite is actually impressive for me
to watch too
is movement movement in this game the
way like hunters will dodge
jump the way i've seen people like
manage the warlock phoenix dash and
some of the stuff i've seen the same
thing with fortnite the people who are
good at building it's like the stuff
outside of just the shooting
that takes somebody to a next level and
this is one of those few games that adds
multiple layers on top of shooting to
make the skill ceiling so so high
absolutely absolutely got 100 agree i
mean that that definitely
and i think also you know for me it's
also been abilities right
because um you know it's besides just
gun play
that power fantasy you feel like you
have more
tools at your disposal and things and
that you can implement
which make it more fun to me and i'm not
really a competitive pvp guy like that's
not really my nature like that most
games
but there was something about destiny
the only that freaked me out was when
i'm
playing it for pvp for the first time
i'm like what's this weird voice
like i wasn't used to shacks when he
first debuted like it was a little
weird i was like is this opera sing a
guy who is this guy talking
like it was just weird like you got to
be real what did you did we all feel a
little
what it took us a while to get adjusted
to shacks i would say
and yeah i was never thrown off by him
like that i was throwing off
he was like part of the game man it just
felt like this very theatrical voice
talking to me and i was just like
whatever it just took me a while he is
stage trained so that fit
yeah but once once we you know once i
got into it
and then like you start to hear more the
nuances and stuff and
i'm like okay i'm getting into it and
he's like this is amazing and i'm all
right cool i'm getting into it
and stuff like that but it was it was
really
unique you know and then the idea of
getting a super
like i i thought that was just so cool
like because again
as a person who doesn't like it just fun
it's like okay
maybe i'm not having the best kd game
but
now my ball is full yeah like you you've
been watching somebody gonna get this
one i'm gonna get a kill
somebody gonna get this somebody's gonna
die with this
yeah he's never bugged me i will tell
you the first time
when you you know he does the work like
the yale the roar when you take down a
super
like he goes i was like that's the first
time he kind of got me i was like whoa
what was that
because it's loud in your earphones it's
like oh okay
yeah they did um but it got to a point
where it d1
i mean even the destiny too i kind of
look forward to it when you get on those
streaks and you get up there
i just want to hear him like just
talking we want to see how ridiculous he
gets now like now we look
forward to it yeah more times like you
know
i really really want to get to the one
where um
the 50 kill one oh god i see i've seen
people get to it
the highest i ever got was 42. but 50
when you get the 50 the man just goes
into this whole soliloquy
how amazing you are and um for a long
time i i just didn't go look at videos
to go see it because a couple people
like frost boating have already got it
and they put it up on youtube
so recently i finally went to go look
and see exactly what he says because i'm
like dude
by the time i if i ever get this it
would be a destiny 3 if they ever make
it
yeah no no no doubt also so you got some
stuff for like
i got stuff lined up after you finish oh
um
we sat there and talked about a whole
bunch of stuff so far uh
short question for you and i'll pass it
back because friend of the show and ilp
of course but uh no a friend of youtube
man
dude appreciate it favorite class
gotta know cause we got a titan as the
cheetah
got a ninja as the warlock you know in
the robes what are you doing oh
what is your class of choices you're
making us all
bad what is it discord remember what i
said your disco would be good to us man
as soon as i said that all right now
he's back yeah i'm backing back okay
there we go
internet freezing and then hold on
stream should come back here in a second
sorry for the audio people i apologize
for
technical difficulties that's discord
no you're good oh no that's like that's
the occasional morning like internet
hiccup i get every so often yeah i'm
literally watching like the frames be
zero it's attempting to reconnect i'm
trying to reconnect
and i i remember i jinxed it i said uh
i was like yo it's been good
and then we in the bushes did you tap on
the table
after you said
[Music]
let me see yeah the stream i see
let's see come back now oh hello hello
we should be good you can blame me
yeah texas internet tornado apparently
or there's a gremlin in my
adrenaline in there we're back we good
welcome back there we go the street
stream had
everything's bigger in texas so
including the mess-ups yeah you're
correct
yep good we got it we back all right so
i was gonna say
we got the titan we got the hunt we got
the warlock forte
what's your class of choice we got to
know how you're getting these 42 kills
we got to see what's up
uh hunter of course oh of course that's
the pvp class so i'm not surprised
exactly is it like warm husk crown 2
nope
oh actually i go different now i i i
do not go meta when it comes to
like the exotics for my class
i use uh i have been maining pretty much
this whole season gemini gestures
the whole season the whole season
remind the listeners and me because
apparently i'm forgetful what do those
do
so whenever you're close to somebody in
proximity and on your radar
if you dodge it disrupts and misdirects
their radar
that's right yeah that'll screw with you
especially with dodgers
oh yeah and i and i run a max mobility
bill so i get mine back every nine
seconds
that's stupid by the way it didn't if
you it didn't it didn't work right
and then what people don't know is if
you put double um
um what is it double perpetual mods on
it lowers it even more really yeah
that doesn't seem right that's too much
dodging i'm sorry you can get it you can
i think theoretically the lowest you can
get is like seven and a half seconds
okay yeah i might get diminishing
returns yeah i might be able to get a
shoulder charge every like 30 seconds
cogs over here doing his thing like
every so often with like melees and get
some builds and
you guys can run devour but man like a
five second dodge just
feels a little bit like cheating that
that feels bad very much
that dodge can't kill you though that
will save your ass though that is true
that is true
well remember when they made it when the
dodge used to have invisibility frames
now yeah yeah yeah then you had a
problem
yeah because we had invisibility frames
i was like yeah this is broken
but they took that away from us a long
time ago
so doubling down on each question with
that like
why hunter what was it that drew you in
and it's like okay not titan not warlock
this is my clan like why um i mean i
think just because of the whole pvp side
of it is like i always look at destiny
as the people
you can definitely tell the people that
are in it for the story in the in a
single player
versus the people that were in front of
multiplayer from day one
like um my background in halo
being a person that literally was like
the best on his team
all the time it said you know
that's the first thing i'll tell you any
hunter that tells you they're humble
they're not
that is true yo hunt just be cocky yo
that's not
don't get that twisted but i think uh
it's just the fact that
playing halo and stuff being one of
those people that was really good at the
game
looking at three classes was like and
plus
they really promoted the hunter in
destiny 1.
i started the hunter was literally in
the middle of everything
all the way up until i think what was it
um rise of iron is when they actually
put a different character as the
focal character on the cover that's when
they put the titans at the front
but other than that every dlc up to that
point hunters were literally the league
like mostly the league character that
was on the cover
so everybody had this fixation it's like
does budgie just love
hunters that much yes they do
i do believe they do but um yeah so that
kind of was
the main reason and then just the lone
wolf mentality
um at that point you didn't have a bunch
of
like i said i have friends that played
it but nothing like i have now
right so i literally ran three hundreds
all the way up into
house of wars three hunters wow three
hunters
oh wow
because that whole well you i think the
first time when i finally
really got into it i only had the one
character i was stuck at that forever 29
yeah and then when i decided to come
back and play
like after master chief collection
gloriously burned itself to
crisp i decided to come back to destiny
and i was like you know what
i got i got the 29 and i was stuck there
for like three weeks i said
i'm just making another character so i
can run this raid again
oh my yeah i was definitely stuck there
for a while on mine
but i still was never to the point of
like making an extra character i don't
know why like i know it was the more
efficient way totally kid it but i was
like i just always had all three forever
well i was always like i love daddle and
i watch his videos all the time and
seeing him run three titans is kind of i
think datto
doesn't realize how influential he was
back then when it came to him picking
one class
and running three characters because
let's be for real
content creators don't think they have
that big of influence but they
do why you think why do you think the
crucible looks like it looks
when it comes to the weapon balance and
stuff that's in there because
yeah people like to use the weapons they
like to use
but they also want to use what's
optimized and most of them don't take
the time to go in
to find that on their own they go look
at outside sources
and if the outside sources are like
super popular they're going to kind of
run with that so
i that's that was part of the reason i
ended up running three characters of the
same class because i saw
datto doing it and i was like yeah i
think that's super efficient
and i just kept running like that all
the way up until
house of wolves and um when um
prison elders came out and then i made a
titan
because i thought titans would be very
valuable with bubbles in there
and i didn't make my warlock into rise
of iron all right
well we got uh some slander in the chat
for you also shout out to
neil mental he said hunters buy squishy
mobile weasels if you ask me
oh and then we have slobo
very uh close to the campfire it says i
have a question for the guest
this gaming forte fella wow is he the
same gaming forte that has a destiny
[ __ ] stamp
also which game has better pvp destiny
or road company so he's being very
slanderous to you right now sir oh
that's a slow-mo pvp
and confirmation or any destiny tattoos
that we need to know about yes there are
destiny tattoos is there a destiny
tattoo
okay okay he spread rumors he's right i
[Music]
where he said it would be at it's
definitely not one there
just literally arrows pointing down to
the butt crack that would not go too
well so that would be bad
fake news it is fake news it is that man
can't
that man can't talk man we remember we
were sitting in the discord
remember we were sitting in the uh in
the discord and that man was playing
destiny hide and seek these division
people always seem to be in destiny i
notice
exactly so but we go we go we go be
petty we ain't going
to see neo mental in there there's a lot
of division guys saluting you guys as
long as you're here
yeah that's what we accept yeah
definitely so yeah hunters man
all day every day but i hear ibots is
that
you used to not always be a titan no it
was
hunter for the first hunter until rides
of iron came out
no yeah no not rise of iron hunter until
taking king
and then am i saying that right yeah
taking king le yeah uh 100 until taken
king
and then taking king it was the fire
hammers with the titan i switched and
they were broken when you got them when
they started
oh remember you
it was literally those and haven't
looked back
i mean i played all three i did stupid
stuff like solo in the nightfalls and
like
fall and saber on my hunter nearly
ruined me
and sadly made somebody like delete one
of their characters i still remember
that tweet that was
because i made the video on like my
titan they're like hey if you do this on
the hunter because the modifiers were
like terrible that week and i finally
bashed my head against the wall enough
so i still would play some but no like
my play time now
skews really heavy titan some warlock
hunter i keep like pulling along with
like the free
armor every season i keep like pulling
them out
i'm so out of practice on a hunter it's
not even funny but i mean that's where i
started
so mm-hmm yes i respect that i respect
it
that's tremendous man it's funny because
you get to see what draws someone to
the class oh deep dive with the hunter
um
favorite subclass with the doctor right
now
void i am top i am top tree all day
touchy boy all day i even in pvp even
knowing that super
absolutely sucks in top in um in pvp
i just like it's something about dodging
going invisible people don't know where
you are
and throw so it's like it throws
everything i literally watch people
turn in like 460 degree angles like
where did this person just go it's
pretty crazy
um other than that it's mostly just um
fuller's executioner on middle tree
if i yeah if i'm doing anything but it
used to be different than destiny one i
was
i was starch gunslinger oh
yeah but once but it's like once they
started taking utility like
throwing knives like didn't
work as good as they used to work one
shot so
once they took well yeah well they
definitely work now um but
i was super in love with sticking people
with sticky grenades
and just watching people literally just
get one shot by them
yes so but once they yeah literally
unicorn
i used to utilize people all the time so
once they stop us doing that
i was like this class isn't funny
anymore
oh you have some of another one of your
uh bra podcast companions
basement ready arcade this new guy who's
in our chat he says
oh yes we had a good chat yesterday
shout out to brad he goes um question
for the guest
why have a 2080 super but play destiny
on console which is the worst way to
play destiny
so that's his he's loving this pc master
race talk right now so he has a question
for the guests just one actually the
easy answer i'll do it for you right now
and i play on pc haven't touched it
since
right now since this man plays pvp he
doesn't want to deal with all the
cheaters he wants that like clean
experience
it's the integrity of the game on pc
it's like is it that good and i hate
that i question that
i absolutely hate that i question the
integrity but in turn
if i don't want to go play in my
molasses mud mode so i'm still going to
deal with that so i can't contact
consoles oh my gosh
they got the chat's coming for you but
continue he's
he's he's he's right 80 of that is
absolutely that the other 20
is my fire team that i play with all the
time is loyalty
their exclusive console and um one of
them
luca shout out to her she's thought
about it
oh yeah she's an exclusive console sorry
exclusive she's exclusively console
she was thinking about coming to pc but
uh my friend taz he's never coming to pc
so it's like he's like no i'll just wait
for the new system to come out
gotcha so um it really meant a lot to me
because dmg
um about i want to say a week ago two
weeks ago did out that put out a tweet
saying you know
who are you who's your fire team tell me
your story
and stuff and um she put out a tweet
talking about us
and i already kind of knew all that
stuff but it was like
really nice to see it come from a third
party perspective
and it lets me know like you know it's
hard it is really
hard switching from pc to console it's
i literally used to play at 105 fov all
the time
but i lit and i would go back and i was
like no this it would literally take an
hour to get acclimated back to what
console was so now
i dumb myself down to 85 um fov
just so it's not as crazy to go back to
72.
that just hurts the soul you're gonna
make the experience worse
that just hurts my soul a little bit
yeah
it's it's terrible but guess what if
these people if if my friends
decide you know it is mostly just those
two those two of all if they come over
their pc
then we're picking you up there you go
see what you're gonna do is convince
he just came over here just to just
appease you for a while no but he's
right
no no no he's right he's right because
once i came over
i brought dudes through i was like look
man
this is where i'm gonna be where you
gonna be at where you gonna be at this
in five months though oh well you got a
serious x-coat exactly 60 frames yeah
but
i'll still go back and forth i'll
probably be eight i'll probably be like
75-80 percent
i'm just announcing the keyboard also
like for me on shooters i even went back
when i played last of us too and i had a
controller in my hand
if i was ever going to try that game on
a hard difficulty i would have to like
somehow like ps5 mouse and keyboard or
something
if that was ever an option because my
aim with the controller is crap
so like that's me it's like i played
mouse and keyboard too much for shooters
for too long
my favorite i'm trash on console that's
the other piece yeah i mean look you we
all got our clans we got our fan
you know you got your family you got
your brother e you know what i'm saying
like i got
like fozzies in the chat i got about
like 70
of my clan is still on xbox so it's
it's tough for me but the cool thing is
gonna have that option to go back
last chat that slow-mo i mean last
question slow-mo i have for you gotta
fight he's the second question forte
could he tell us if it's worth buying a
series x for 60 frames in destiny to
play with friends
even though cross play is coming next
year yes because i'm not waiting
not waiting i look i i look at this
stuff a whole lot different than other
people do as much as yes it's
five six hundred dollars i still say six
hundred dollars slow mo can
he can um take that to the bank but uh i
say
six but i think the fact that i'm
getting rid of i'm getting rid of one of
my
my xbox one x's that's going to help
with the price of it
but i just feel like at a certain point
why
not enjoy the thing that you play the
most
like i play destiny every day
fax and if you're gonna play a game
every day no matter where you play that
you want to have the best experience
possible and right now
the only good thing about console is the
fact that the people i'm playing with
other than that
everything else is horrible not for you
so that's respectable i mean at the end
of the day
you listen loyalty we they call it the
what was the deeds one time you got
trouble to say that but he said it's the
friend game right there
they explained the game that you at the
end of the day that's what it is i mean
we all
have we have to admit if you're a fan of
destiny we all
have those favorite people to play the
game with
and that experience you can't really
match that anyway so you're gonna go
where your friends are and i completely
completely understand that that makes
that makes perfect sense in your case
but i do like the fact that um as i've
been on pc like i wouldn't have known
eban just if i didn't come to pc
i mean so i i do i do appreciate
the people that i have met and played
with on pc yes
more than anything and yeah that kind is
like the great equalizer the biggest
thing for me is pc is more of the system
that i like to do a lot of my solo stuff
on
yes so yeah i will
there's definitely a reason for that but
people always say well you always say
you're about your friends and stuff but
you play
predominantly by yourself on pc i was
like yeah because it's a lot easier to
do things on pc when you're by yourself
you don't realize that until you do it
though right
yeah it's a different animal when you're
going for that type of control
especially when you want like
just harder stuff as long as like the
cheating's not involved if it's pve
yeah i mean ask anybody out there it's
like be like yeah it's like first day
raid stuff like that mostly everybody
who has an option they'll be on pc no
question
yeah exactly absolutely so i'm going
quarter oh my god i'm caught up with a
question but the
chat seems to be
last question we gotta go get crap yeah
uh
question for the guest haven't played
destiny in 10 months would it be
difficult to jump
back in have you not played it 10 months
for real
where have you been under a rock
apparently he
probably definitely has been he's been
playing a lot of war zone unfortunately
um it's not hard to jump back in right
now
um right now it's probably the easiest
time to jump back in because it's like a
really
slow low in the in the content loop just
because
they extended everything by a month and
a half to two months already
so you can really get caught up
depending on where you were at before
i would say jump in now just because a
lot of stuff is about to leave the game
um especially like stuff that you like
exotics and stuff that
normally would be there uh we don't know
how they're gonna be attainable
in the future so like um he did a really
good video
uh so check out the video he did where
he talked about a lot of the exotics and
planets that were going away
uh so check that out because all that
stuff is very very relevant
to knowing what's gonna happen in the
game so um if you can jump in now
but other than that you can just wait to
november and
pretty much i think they're probably
going to do the same thing they did with
the last dlc
yeah where everybody gets that um boost
to
whatever the light level normally is so
everybody will start at the same
level again so it's it's two
uh two words of thought just wait or
jump in now and get as much stuff as you
can because
who knows what's going to happen with
like certain weapons like gnawing hunger
when this season is over are they going
to be still
in the game especially since right now
that gun can be used all the way through
season four of next year right so it
really just depends on
your your time commitment yeah i mean
that's the biggest thing is to
right now is before a lot of things get
sunset and while there's many things
that get sunset
probably need to go um i would say more
it's your experience of you've got the
full breadth of
activities if you want to uh and we do
have like 100 days which is stupid
because i was like it's july 31st i was
like
when's this game come out not september
not october
not august that's three months november
10th i was like it's literally a hundred
days away it's like god we have a long
time
so like you got plenty of time to come
in jump up leveling up at this point if
you just play the regular activities the
blues are gonna get you up to a thousand
pretty damn fast at least on one
character even if you haven't played in
about a year like whatever that level
jump is and maybe it's like 900 to 1050
or whatever you're going for
it's not going to be too bad and the
amount of time you've got and the other
p
reason i would say it is this season is
setting up a connection to beyond light
that is probably like nothing else
they've ever done
the way they're setting up the pyramid
ships the way they're setting up
potentially the evacuation missions
if there's going to be a live event
things like that the way it's going to
tie into next season
to head to europa to lose planets this
is probably one of the coolest seasons
story-wise narratively world building
and all the stuff that they've ever done
but i would say if you just jump into
beyond light i think it'll be cool
but i think if you jump in before and
build up to it it's gonna be
so much better my two cents yeah i think
the biggest thing is what you just said
is with the planets disappearing
you know the last time you played this
game you had a crap ton of planets on
your director
and you're gonna log in in in november
and be like
what happened yep and you kind of want
to be a part of that you know um people
already missed the
almighty depending on how you feel about
how that event went i thought it was
great
i saw i saw so many people
just sitting in the tower waiting for
something to happen now
we can definitely get on we could
definitely get a budget about the
execution of letting people know how
long it's gonna
take to do it but i i have fun because
my daughter jumped in destiny literally
the week before that got her leveled up
to character she was in the tower
standing next to me
that's fantastic so she's nine
so if it felt amazing to have
somebody in that world
to experience an event like that even
how much school it is but that's what
destiny is destiny is about
the minuscule things that become bigger
over time
not true brother true man that's what i
got e we got anything else going on in
this book oh i was gonna say i think we
got the full man's gaming history
life history social security number
credit report
he got he got his own questions section
i've never seen a guess we have
they have their questions
when i saw it i was like oh this is a
requirement cool don't bro you break it
all type of records
oh no the questionnaire i sent you is
yeah but the ones coming through chat
those are not common
you got you got oh you got haters in
chat mostly so they're just trying to
burn you
that's really what's happening but they
hate that in love we haven't got that
those are good people shout out to deal
men too brad and slovo via silly
huge fans they part of the basement
radio arcade podcast and the skype cast
so um these guys definitely are friends
with fun they even it's our complete
sarcasm y'all
these guys are really friends with forte
they just give them a hard time because
they're here
everybody everybody 140. yeah why don't
y'all drop this man a
sub while y'all in here too oh man
since you guys are up in here you know
remember remember how we work on the
iron lures we only read in color
so uh i should be i should be required
like sub only i would never do that
oh we can't do it we need some we need
some sub love up in here so i'll hit
this man up
uh but i was gonna say like so
where we're at in destiny 2 right now as
i said we have 100 days till the end of
the season
potentially what was going to happen is
september 22nd comes around which would
be about six weeks away
we'd have solstice of heroes which
starts a week and a half from now
and then we'd be rolling into the end of
the season everything just got pushed
way way far out
which does mean for a lot of people have
seen some people knocking out seals
those of you who are doing like
reckoning and one reckoner in one week
y'all are crazy
i've seen that on twitter they're losing
their mind uh
saw a couple shadows pop up so i mean
season seals are a decent thing to go
for
i do want to work on conqueror this
season just because it does seem
painful but you have your arsenal of
everything so if something like
mountaintop or anything specifically
helpful for one i'm gonna have all the
picks
and then when it comes to like next
season when everything goes away at
least i'll have that box checked but i
guess what i wanted to catch from you
guys is what are you doing in destiny
right now i'm kind of curious
yeah what you do what you're doing
currently forte
uh so remember last season i was working
towards
my um i was working towards my reckoner
title
yes i started that back up again because
of
i i i don't know what's going to happen
with
reckoning and i don't know what's going
to happen with the
um when they're gonna add these two
modes together uh however they're gonna
do it and i think there's a good chance
that the title may go away
and as of right now every title in this
game
has some value but the recorder title to
me
even knowing it's not the hardest to get
it's the most insane one to get it's
like when you see it
when you see somebody with that title
you know they've seen things
that they shouldn't have seen things
and um you they have done things that
they should not have done
the fact that right now that i don't
have this title yet and i still i have
close to 700
prime evil kills wow lets me know how
much i play
this game so i have one more carry i
need to finish out my uh
sentry class and i'll be done with it so
i've been working on that
and then um i'm working last season i
got my flawless tag so
that was that was interesting because i
got because of pc
stay away from them cheaters bro get
that clean experience out there exactly
yeah exactly
worked on that and then now um i started
working
earlier this week on my flawless run for
prophecy and i want to go i want to be
like ibanez i want to have all three of
them done
um so you know i've been looking at his
videos seeing how
he did um his other ones and stuff so
that's what i've been
doing over the course of like the last
three four weeks
what you got what you've been playing
have you been playing this or
are there cherry blossoms flirting with
you
so day right now man it's like it's like
what they said it's like um
you know since this season was just
on fire from the beginning but again
once we got the delay
and then we knew things were going to
get extended so and i was so
like every day every week in pocket
what's going on okay boom right around
effigy then i'm like okay i got
everything yeah
like you know i was in pocket i was you
know i was doing my thing you know
and it's just like you know once that
happened and i'm like all right well i
got
because i kind of slowed down like all i
got to let do left is the effort she
decided through an eyes with that shout
out to your video still not or did you
do it
i'm like halfway through i just gotta
it's just busy it's it's just do it for
one night it's not that long
knock out i recorded that thing faster
and then it's probably taken you to do
it
that video long it takes about like a
five
minute video you did it real time almost
and it'll take you like an hour
one hour yeah that's a commitment
it's a commitment from busy work it's
busy work
go here look at the ceiling look at the
corner look behind the cupboard
catalyst either like bro i don't want to
really do this it's just like
i'm just doing it for the sake of
completionist and the fact that i am
that close
to what is it forerunner so i'm like all
right if i don't do it it's stupid
because i'm
literally that close to getting the
title so i'm like all right so
i just got i was just like all right
i'll put it off i'll do it what i gotta
do and the another reason why i
stopped to be honest is that once it got
extended and i'm like why am i rushing
i got the time in the world to do all
this stuff so that was the first thing
but um for me
it's more been loadouts um prepping
myself
for the whole sun setting bit getting
myself out
of using i do not use recluse anymore i
do not use
mountain top anymore just because i want
to mentally get myself
out of those crutches because i know
they're not going to be there
you know for beyond light and the last
thing just yeah because
just messing with lord i actually got a
fun little loadout now obviously knowing
hunger we all agree we all loving
knowing hunger right now i got my
subsistence and a rampage roll
i'm rocking but i went back to shout out
to tram because he mentioned inject
i went back to izanagi i went back to
izanagi now i know the dps is slow
ever since the thing but the way i look
at it now my ultimate loadout right now
is knowing hunger izanagi at um in the
connect and then
um the sword the guillotine so it's like
i feel i could handle any situation if
something if
you got rangers close i got the range
and yo
izanagi still hit like a truck it's just
the reload animation is slow
because they want to you know slow down
on the dps but i'm having up
like i was doing the uh i do the contact
missions when the you know interference
when it comes up on
the reset i have a ball shooting them
eyes with this and i'm just
blasting that thing out the sky like
it's just fun man so i really love that
build
i've been messing with that and um
slo-mo said cocky's volatile
listen i had to use it was god tear i
mean you if you weren't using
mountaintop in pve
it was kind of a you were kind of
handicapping yourself
it's just that for me right now i know
it's going away because of the sun
setting but that's been pretty much i
just been really uh prepping for that
just light jump in
do my little reset do my little
pinnacles get up out of there and it's
all about ghosts and
cherry blossoms and all that good stuff
from ghosts and sushi well that's what
i've been doing
to be honest until the stuff but we'll
talk about the raid away but what you
said forte
no i'll say i i can't lie man like for
me when it comes like you just named
some weapons that i just haven't been
able to pull myself away from yet
like i love my mountaintop yeah i
try to get my i'm trying to get my
mountain top to ten thousand kills
before
the season's out it's close it's like at
night it's like
873 um yeah 800
8 07 732 that's what it's at
but let me get let me get hampton real
quick he's i mean i had to um set free
say it's a crutch he said i don't touch
the crutch i'm
going to kill more players than me and
straight no i'm not saying it's not a
skill web but i'm just saying
oh no he's literally saying he watched
me while i did my solo flawless runs
die to that moan weapon
yeah no yeah okay so with the gd geek i
don't think he's in here right now but
he's like yeah the ultimate raid boss is
mountain top to kill yourself
yeah i cannot tell you how many times
i've died to my own weapon it's
special to kill yourself with it oh for
sure for sure i'm just talking about
from pure optimal loadout standpoint
so i've i hate it's like loose in a
while i will say like i haven't used
that in a while
well i got my hunger i made my video
about that i can't put that thing down
with some systems right now i like your
your build on that one too
like system page fan page that's the one
i got now granted
you can get the overflow rampage from
the curated roll which is from reckoning
tier three
you can do that subsistence now the
difference is
somebody's got to remind me and somebody
clarify the way overflow works i know
somebody said like even a comment on the
video was like hey i can get 96 bullets
in it
and that's if you pick up like a green
brick or something like that you'll get
96 bullets but you have to reload to get
the 96 everything
and not like so for example in that
video i went through 400 bullets without
reloading
maybe once bro just by firing it out so
it's like
both are going to have benefits i could
see either being good but i'll say the
form ability of the subsistence rampage
bro or swashbuckler either one's going
to be pretty viable um the trash mob
think about when you did the contact
mission yeah
this week and you go over the bridge
and those thralls come to you if you got
subsistence rampage
you just sit on the trigger and you just
see the bullets just keep coming back to
you
it almost is like uh um it's like
substance is almost like a mini
no time to explain perk where the
bullets just keep coming back into your
mag
all the time so it you just and then you
got the triple
rampage kicking in oh you can have
tremendous fun like
it's just it's the ultimate trash mob i
love
that roll but i had to give it up shout
out to that roll no no like that's i
used that pretty much the whole way
through the dungeon
except for the boss tube uh
used a bow in there for the bob goblins
but outside of that like non-hunger's
been good
yeah i have been using a lot of
mountaintop and pve mostly because i
have also been working on solo prophecy
i finished that so i've been enjoying
that one
i want to go back through and flip and
try to like say forward path because i
got a freedom feeding
i would go truth teller so to flip it so
truth teller with leg
because i have a feeding frenzy multi
coat truth teller
unfortunately that one only has blinding
in concussion so the blast radius is
like
that big it's like tiny no spike i don't
think i've got one with spike
yeah you gotta get so that's the one i'm
looking for is with spike
to see if i can get that one and then
and then i'm trying to figure out
because then i want to go back through
if i make
because i could do a solo prophecy guide
right now with like
my xenophage mountaintop and i'm like
not everybody has all that crap and
that's always what i try and do if i
make a guide i'm going to be like all
right let me go completely just like
this season truth teller
uh forward path maybe for an auto rifle
or even that other one whatever the
newest slower one is
and then like i'm trying to figure out
heavy without sword of course in the
first part but then like
interference maybe for a grenade
launcher there's not a machine gun this
season which is like
kind of a bummer i've been trying to
figure out what to go in the heavy slot
god bless you sir god bless you
try to do all that for these for these
people
i'm sitting there as i'm listening to
you saying that i'm like
no well so the funny thing i've said it
before like when the first boss where
normally i'd use the sword i was messing
around switching and i was trying
truth-teller and the blinding grenade
actually works surprisingly well
you shut like a night down and they're
just like mosing around for a little bit
they're pretty easy to hit with the
second one the blinding is
stupidly helpful but i had that and i
switched
i had that and mountain top and a sword
and i still managed to finish the first
thing again with two grenade launchers
like i know truth teller is beneficial
and then if i compare that with an auto
rifle it's doable
my worry is actually the cube room
without xenophage because i crutch it so
hard
that's where i gotta figure out cause
it's three shots on
and it's exotic technically you should
be able to go get xenophage
but it's three shots on the nights and
i'm like i don't know how i can match
that
now mm-hmm with just like this season's
weapon or something
yeah i'd have to say it's gonna be tough
yeah i agree that's gonna be
very tough to do without that zeno
really helps with a lot
of those those are i mean i'm the dumb
guy who use that on the boss damage as
opposed to anarchy like everybody else
everybody loves anarchy yeah yeah but
knowing that no one actually had it
yeah yeah oh my um
solo run right now i am running uh
mountaintop of course
running anarchy and i'm running um
because it has um it does dual things so
i have suspicious
as everybody else has on it i have i
have kill clip on my eyes but i also
have
demolition um
so i use kill clip all the way up into
the final room then i use demolition in
the final room
because i keep feeding my anarchy back
yep it's for the boss
yeah taking on vince's key oh yeah yeah
taking our images um
taking barriers you're speaking about
people don't realize that if you have
fallen if you have fallen arguments you
get double drops
because they're falling enemies in there
mm-hmm because technically
they're falling taken so they can take
i gotta get in scourge man i gotta get
that get that popping it's funny you
said that's what i was doing
i've been um farming the shout out to
your video what you have up to
and jarv who we have oh hey we had on
the last word
i've been farming the ray chest yeah
shout out to forte for for teaching a
warlock how to jump correctly to get his
chest
he was so helpful to me he yelled at me
at first yeah he was yelling at me
but he was gonna be yo he got me to
relax he taught
he said this is how you floof cog he's
like you got to jump up here
and this was see he's a hunter he's so
used to that agility
so he forgets that my clunky warlock
self can't make these jumps that he does
precision i've done whisper solo on all
three characters if i can do that on a
warlock
you don't get to tell me a hug can't
jump this
that's not an option this is a hunter to
warlock this is a warlock to hunt
appreciation threat right now okay you
stay out of it type here's the deal
he that's my man shot to eat
but he really really showed me like i
had to i had to learn how to do it they
show me the correct branch
to get my chest man so i've been
following my little taking
he was getting mad too bro every time he
died
he's like why this freaking branch won't
clamber oh
there's something about the floof right
this is what i hate when you're going up
when you go down as a warlock it's great
glad you know you're kind of cruising
the way you want to go
love it tap tap yeah and did you hear
the sound but when you go
up the thing i hate is the hunter will
make the landing
and then slip and i'm like why did you
even make the landing to begin with
and not just stay there like it's like
he has slippery feet i'm like what is
going on
now depth perception it's called
gum and it's called why isn't the
clamber
working that's it's a glitch warlock
fans talk to me am i bugging
yes warlocks know what i'm talking about
when you
make the jump as a warlock you're not
pressing the directional pad
and then he's in control with the mouse
and keyboard so look at the head yes
maybe it's a controller thing
and it just he slips off and i'm like
why why
so that was my frustration that one day
but uh forte showed me yeah he yelled at
me too he said i said
you gotta do is this and that was he
said you and he bought this and you guys
always y'all
y'all y'all think it comes easy for
y'all you know you you gotta
you gotta go take a warlock in the same
place you're jumping oh stop
i'll jump right with you so i had to
literally do what he said
he after he got on me you know cuz i'm
i'm very
very influential to what cognito says to
me he starts yelling at me i'm like oh i
must have did something wrong
so so i said okay god you go
you go this way he's telling me jump on
this rock
yes you know once you jump on this rock
don't jump again
yes take your time yes yes he gave me
good instruction y'all it was very very
very informative
we literally had to take it down to like
point five speed mm-hmm
yeah youtube played back speed and then
i got it
shout out to funny central i'm flew for
life but i don't know man
it isn't that bad at the same
dude you time land better than the rest
of us so if you're talking about an
issue with landing i
can't empathize man you're like hold on
it's like
landing parachute landing the parachute
landing yeah
no that's easy we're talking about going
up you keep talking about going down
that's easy up is the foolishness but
anyway shout out to back warlocks don't
have a jump it's a drift to their death
even the person who designed the jump
said it was a mistake facts
factual man i think titans have it the
hardest when they come down because
every time i come down with my titan i
feel like i hit
i hit that jump button you guys have air
brakes hunters get another jump in the
bottom i have to stop my
like competitive heresy when i'm falling
i have to start my slow fall halfway
down the thing so i don't smash my legs
into my head
break your legs yeah yeah i give them i
give them that every time i do that i'm
like
what is i say you always miss time to
fall it's like you'll still
die like when you're doing pit and
you're jumping off the cliff for the
first time
to um define the different uh where
where all the different
enemies are acropolis yeah yeah i'm
sitting there like
why did i just die i was like oh because
literally
the brakes on this thing doesn't work
yeah there's no there's no drinks it's
like
so you guys have like air you guys have
like like sports car brakes
i'm driving like an 18-wheeler i gotta
hit the brakes way
back way before the stop light to ease
that slow down in otherwise i'm plowing
straight through that intersection and
i'm gonna die
yeah man it's crazy so funny the
different experiences for each of our
classes it's so
funny man but that's destiny man that's
that's what yeah
that's pretty much what i'm doing
farming trying to get those taken mods
doing that i got to get the fala march
and then uh i think addicts up this week
so
sunday and from sunday on we'll probably
get back into our full-time rating so
forte you are all more than welcome if
you guys did
i got checkpoints for um scourge if you
need them nice i needed the
checkpoint for what the sparrow run for
the chests
yeah you got this browser yeah i have
that too i had that on another character
well the thing about people don't
realize the thing about
scourge is the fact once you get a
checkpoint you keep it forever
until you um either complete it or you
until you complete it
you basically just keep saying
characters through
yeah nice never it never leaves even
during reset it's the one raid that
does not lead the checkpoint doesn't
leave really yes
budgie knows this at this point wow
we're gonna get into that so cause
is it there for blacksmith right don't
you have to have a perfect run
with the sparrow well it's a perfect
raid yeah it's a perfect race party
because that's the hardest part
right that's so hard people yeah six
people doing a perfect run
perfect power one that's good no that's
why i ain't got it yep
that's why i got it the thing that i i
think the thing that kind of
um makes people not really want to do it
is because it's not like you could just
go into the raid and do it you have to
activate it yes you have to literally go
around in that one you got to go to all
the different
pillars inside the city and you have to
forcibly activate it instead of just
saying
hey if we make it through this without
dying we get the flaws
get it yeah you gotta do the wish for
last wish don't you you have to do the
flawless wish you got to do that
or something yeah yeah mm-hmm which is
fine but that goes with the aesthetic of
that raid you know i could
kind of yeah i kind of understand it but
it's like
wow we got to turn on all these beacons
just to just to initiate this bone just
to initiate this
they kind of got rid of that with the
newer ones which i'm um
happy yeah along with um
dumbing down um guarding salvation so
you don't have to have the flawless for
it anymore
yeah absolutely so what's going on in
the world of destiny
uh well this week we had the prophecy
dungeon
deep dive uh if you guys haven't had a
chance to watch that one from bungie it
is fantastic
uh shout out to brendan thorne and
andrew hopps especially
nicole she was the one running the show
my man john toe
he was killing it too yeah oh yeah there
were so many people
like so many people in there but it was
one of the things that i think made my
mind explode
which part is you start with the circles
then you got the half circle then you
got the desert
then you're up to the cube and then
you're to the triangle and it's
literally
shifting from the traveler and the light
as you go through
to the darkness and the pier the pyramid
in the triangle and i was like
oh dude i lost my mind when i put all
that together that was so
so cool to see how they like build the
transition in that and we know it's the
space of the nine and the light versus
the dark and it's that whole theme right
now
where we're thinking about the darkness
and the light and the traveler and the
pyramids and the witch queen and
lightfall like
ever this is why again why i said like
getting into destiny 2 right now to at
least keep up with the story
i think this time's going to be special
to see what comes in the fall so that
was
that one little part was just like
that's the one i can't forget it's just
like seeing how they have that little
whiteboard moment from like
circle fading in flat for the desert
come back out
cube and then triangles like oh that's
too that's too perfect
yeah what did you guys take out of that
with any big moments any cool things
that you guys got out of it
what did you get a chance to watch it
you watched it right yeah yeah i watched
it no
that was pretty much because the one
thing i always appreciate the most about
those rider lawns is just
the scope and where the conception of
where they started is where they finish
that light i'm with you when i saw
the whole everything put together and
them say it how it was done i was like
that's interesting you would never
thought about it that way
um by a person that just plays the game
in the normal way it's like you're
getting that bird's eye view of the
overview of it
um i was really looking forward to
seeing if there was a way that you can
see
the uh where you were going because that
was like kind of the trend they had for
every
dungeon like you know when you're in
shatter throne you look up you can see
the top where you're actually going to
be at you go to um you go to a pinasar
apparel heresy you can see the pit from
where you started so i'm like
this one it's kind of a little bit
harder like you said because of the way
they
designed it and how you're
transmissioning through dimensions and
stuff
but um seeing that it was like oh yeah
this is this is cool and it's starting
to seem like bungie
is really catching their stride and how
we want them to be able to tell stories
that matter to what we're doing now
yeah instead of trying to trying to just
finish up a storyline so they can get to
the next one it's like
we're finally transitioning where
everything's starting to make sense all
together
and that was very apparent in what they
were talking about
in um this dungeon right along um so i
really appreciated that i just like
overall the aesthetic of this raid it's
like yeah oh yeah
it's it's like one of the it's probably
not the most beautiful thing they did
but technically the way the
the environments are very vast you can
straight up get lost in
in the desert and um
i like how they just implement little
set pieces inside of the dungeon and
make you feel
um feel claustrophobic especially like
in a cube room
i like the mechanic of uh i mean the
first time i beat it
i was like stuck i was like where's the
freaking
where's talon i don't know where he is
and i didn't realize that he was on top
and you got to go
to the you had to go to the blank side
of the wall
where that's the side you have to drop
at so just being able to see
implementations of stuff like that is
the things that i like seeing because
it's one thing playing it but it's the
whole a whole nother thing to see that
a developer has something in mind for
you to
yeah to accomplish but then you found a
different way of doing it because they
always get surprised when people find
out like oh
we didn't expect people to be able to do
it that way but guess what that's i mean
that's why we building the way they have
they're pretty open in a way that you
can attack them from different ways
yeah it was it was good it was one it
was one of the ones i was very glad that
i watched i like they had the
whole zoom set up so many members of the
team
you know they really got a chance to
break down a lot of stuff um i like i
said
shout out to john toe i love the
narrative aspect you know just talking
about the nine how they conceptually
thought about the world
what they were trying to say and he did
mention
you know about the each in the desert
each planet you know
that is going to go it's going what was
represented
um a lot like i like the uh last boss
fight they talking about that tunnel
they were talking about how they were
constructing that fight and as far as
the whole um
the teleport thing and sending you back
yeah i also like how
they were they said two things that were
very interesting to me one thing they
said
is like how sometimes when they make it
in their internal test they're like no
this is too ridiculous yeah we gotta
take a number of nights
yeah the numbers nice he said we gotta
take this night out
cause this was just really i was
thinking about that room and i'm like yo
that room is crazy because you got
you know the guy on you know on each
side there were three nights instead of
two in the final one there were four
nights
in the first section they said they had
to back one out of each
now the thing that really blew my mind
is that they said dungeons are
constructed
with the solo player in mind
first that blew my mind i thought it
would be the opposite that you designed
with the full fire team because she
asked them you know you know do you guys
intend
for your you know these dungeons to be
solo they were like well that's how they
were designed
by one person then they kind of ramp up
so i thought that was very interesting
to see that like that it was just dope
like they are so
talented man and again you know just
when
this is again we gotta we gotta talk our
destiny talk like this is why
destiny is that game it's like when it
comes to end game
content the things that they come up
with like
it's just it's mind-blowing the talent
on this team
is really impressive you know even like
i said
the room where you you know like you
everyone you're talking about forte when
with tone land and everything like that
you know the design from the ribbon
down to initially they had yeah oh did
you see the slides
that would have been dope it's so crazy
the initial concept
of the sparrow run was initially like a
slip and slide
down the joint i was like yo that would
have been fire too
like i couldn't even get mad like then
they showed like a concept of the um my
only beef though i would have asked him
this
is my uh you know what i'm talking about
i don't know
what i do actually when you go dump
either the black
moat or the white one right the dark or
the light yeah
i would have been like why didn't you
put a mechanic
a normal indicator over it to dunk
remember like the game really doesn't
tell you how to dunk the thing correctly
right so they they talked about i don't
know if you saw this e they showed the
initial design
of where you dunk it how it was
initially gonna look and it was gonna
have one was gonna have like a dome
but then they said that looked too much
like a titan bubble then they had one
that almost like a splotch on the floor
like they had these different conceptual
things it was just really
interesting like i i love stuff like
that i love deep dives
i personally think prophecy is the best
dungeon they've done
i'm going to be honest like i just think
from start to finish i'll tell you that
definitely i love that boss fight that
just going down that long
tunnel the chase you gotta chase him
he's throwing the thing at you you could
get sent back like
it's just so much to it man i really
enjoy it shout out to them man they
they are so talented man that's just one
small team
that has done something and every time
they knocked out the park so yeah i'm
i was glad i watched it late but i'm
glad i did watch it i was like yo that
was super informative yeah
yeah the thing i like like you said the
thing i really like and it really does
speak to how they build it it's like
it's like how they did king's fall where
they built hard
and uh they just scaled it back for
normal which
i wish they get back to how rays were
done in d1
but that when he said that i was like
you know what that makes sense because
you build it around the hall you build
it around the ability to do it by
yourself which is the hardest way to do
it but
we scale it back for you can do it with
three people whereas
we don't change anything the only
difference is you're just it's more
it's more manageable to do when you're
with three people versus how
harder it is when you're by yourself so
it's like dave
took that same philosophy from rey's and
bring it over which i like the most
but the one thing i will i'll fight you
against is the whole dunking mechanic
i think they hold your head way too much
in this game as it is
and literally the first time i did i was
like how do you dunk this thing
that i was like i just but i just went
over just push buttons on it i was like
oh okay you just hold the right trigger
i just think they hold your hand too
much in this game as it is for certain
things you do and
i get it i understand like the first
time but think about it the first time
you do it and you figure it out
it's like oh okay then it's over you
don't know
one time i get i just feel like a weird
extra step that i just thought was
interesting it's not an extra sub
circuit it's an extra step no it's just
the next time
it's an extra minute it's literally a
quick time event that's all it is
yeah it's ridiculous anyway like i would
say the whole thing is just though
there was dope about that mechanic real
real talk though is
how they talked about from a design
standpoint
how they could even do light and dark
and in your relationship to where you
stand and how they initially had it
was they handed me the enemies stood oh
and i was crazy
i would have been crazy if they left it
like that so um yeah oh shout out to cat
daddy the chat salute
you know part of the clan and everything
but uh yeah like that
again who thinks of these things forte
like who thinks of these things like
they they are just amazing when it comes
to endgame content
and dungeons man they just every every
time
every time they're knocking out the park
man much smarter people than we are
coming up with this stuff and i think we
come up that's the thing i always um
get on people about armchair developing
it's like you don't realize how much
work goes into the stuff that these
people make
we critique this we critique these raids
and these dungeons and the
activities we do in this game uh because
to us
it seems like oh this was simple why
didn't they think of this
but ultimately you got to think how many
people are working on these things
how many how much certification they got
to go through to get yeah
um it when you go from conception to a
complete thing
it's probably hundreds of hundreds if
thousands of hours
have been consumed to do that so um
whenever i see these um
whenever i see these developer diaries
and stuff on things like this it's like
truly amazing just to see a small group
of people especially in the dungeons
um really come together and put
something together like they did with
this one because
no one thought they were gonna get a
dungeon with this yeah this was a
complete surprise to me and again
another reason why i gotta shout out my
boy
biggest fan john tor i'm the biggest fit
he wrote like 300
lines of dialogue in this raid i'm like
yo this is crazy like again just the
conversation between the drifter
and maula with it with um eris and
you know you're getting those little
lore pieces we know about the infamous
um you know shaq's is kind of possessed
kind of thing like we learned that you
don't get that stuff from a lot of you
know
like they really knocked this one out
the park man again
not no disrespect to shadow throne love
it no disrespect to pit of heresy both
fantastic
it's just something about i think it's
for me it's the aesthetic it's the
aesthetic combined with the mechanics
i just really i really like this joint
well shout out to aries because last
night we ran all three
nice we did back to back to back so we
did chatter thrown
cleared that did two man pit of harrison
yep two men to the mall
bit of harrison and then prophecy which
i ended up doing flawless
by accident i mean
there was one we were running through i
think it might have been shattered
thrown we were just going along it was
just like hey we gonna do it flawless
and we're like
walking up the first bridge when the
belt just died like a glitch and i was
like
i can throw that out the window uh but
we knocked all three out in about an
hour and 45 minutes so we
burned through pretty quickly yeah it
was
but it was like after playing them back
to back to back and kind of refreshing
the mind of like yeah
it was defined i mean like prophecy
hardest for sure no question um
and still just like the unique nature
the light and dark and then
now that we got the deep dive as well
it's like just getting more of an
understanding of like
the lore pieces and the transition from
the like the circle to the triangle it's
like it almost makes me appreciate it
more
yeah it's like shattered thrown as you
said i love looking up and then looking
down but it's like i know they can't
keep repeating that well you don't want
to just keep going up and down and like
traversing forever so like this one like
going through dimensions and everything
but i mean i would say like
they've learned stuff from each one so i
mean they're gonna have like
some crazy encounter in there like the
cube room or chamber of suffering or the
ogre they're gonna have the boss fight
which is
has some slow queen what's up what's
going on
red queen hey how you doing you knock my
boy out queen
i'm supposed to like you but i'm not
supposed to like you but i still like
you so yeah
yeah yeah enjoy your tasty food we'll
see you later
shut up tell jigsaw he got to come on to
make he got to come on the last word to
make up for that transgression
salute to your food choices she's good
she was about to have reese's cereal i
was like hey that sounds pretty good if
you're gonna have cereal like having
reese's in it like in a bowl but yeah
jigsaw we're looking for you sir
you flipped up the answer order some
evil that was such a fun thing what was
the boy's name the horse he was really
cool
oh james work yeah
if you guys haven't watched it the red
queen was on he was on
a lot of very good destiny content
creators
four good calls for veterans i believe
and um yeah
they knocked it out the park it's it's
it was a podcast battle royal
and it's down to the last couple of
questions unique i love the concept
really fun shout out to even the cops
here like it see yeah
fire is like it's hot in here
they're coming for you man but yeah i
was like playing them back to back to
back
prophecy is something special because i
would say
it had them like just the right amount
of mechanics but it had more mechanics
than the rest to make it
just a step above i think the light
versus the dark
remotes and like those pieces
all of that just kind of takes it just
to tear above and i think they just keep
learning from each dungeon like
shattered throne they went through they
had these the encounters and you had
like a traversal section when you have
like kind of like the
the desert you have your like they said
like it doesn't always need to be like
crazy encounters everywhere it's like
sometimes you just need to shoot some
taken
yes i like that he said that i was like
that's kind of perfect because there are
some words like the descent and
shattered throne or
um like the wizard section when you're
going through all the different
platforms and pit there's certain
sections where it's just like
go around and shoot the enemies like
whether it's like trying to figure out
which direction to go maybe a thing but
not everything has to be like all right
you got to dunk this here you got to
manage these mechanics three different
but like
not everything has to be that way
otherwise you might go insane like there
has to be some
in between like the rainbow road was
cool so playing them back to back to
back i mean i think it does go
shadow thrown is special because it's
first but then pedopharacy learned and
zolamak is just like a fanta it's not
just like
i mean dylan carter looks pretty cool
with the knights but zolomek is
just monstrous and you got now the sword
mechanics that you've learned
and then pit of heresy takes it to the
next takes it to the next level so
the dungeons i think have continued to
get better if i'm gonna rank them it's
like you know
one two three like newest to oldest so
it's like
prophecy pitch shattered throne i would
put them in that order
it's so good man yeah shout out to yeah
i just love i love that they exist you
know what i'm saying because at the end
of the day not everyone has a full
ray team you know rage do take a lot to
get
organized and this dungeon really it's
that happy medium and again a mechanic
a thing that we didn't think we would
ever get with discount for this
expansion and then in general you know
the fact that they just continue to
produce good content when they do it so
salute to the team
so what do you guys think about um the
budget disappearing how y'all feel i'm
you go first i'm gonna probably like say
a little too much so you go ah
you about to go in you're about to go in
i'm going to go
almost a bad way mine's actually more
and lower questions so you go first oh
okay right yeah it's
well i mean the thing is they did say
it's coming back right they just say
it's right it's temporarily going to go
um my guess could be it's either a
logistic
thing you know whether it be well i
don't know whether it be with the
content vault or something like that
or the fact that it's in the tower
technically when you when you started
off
so maybe it's a logistic thing a
technical thing it is weird i i was
surprised when they said it was going to
go
and then try to bring it back as quickly
as possible it's got to be either one of
these either logistic thing from a
technical standpoint
or from a lore standpoint something is
going to happen
that it just doesn't make sense to be
there right right now and
that's the only thing i can think of but
well like yeah
jumping i was heading in the direction i
was thinking too and it's
the because like drift you're sitting in
the tower right now
is he gonna be out in europa is like is
gambit gambit gambit prime is that gonna
be a thing where's his ship gonna be so
all that stuff is a piece
and then you picture like the desert
area you have the four planets that are
going away
right if it comes back what that like
how is that going to be a reference are
they going to have different like
little kind of things in the desert area
and they can keep
most of it look the same right but keep
the little pieces of like
kind of the little remnants of the areas
do that as like
maybe you got a europa piece maybe you
got a nessus piece maybe you got a
couple of the planets that remain
and they switch it up that way lore wise
and then it's also this is the prophecy
of like these are all the locations
going away the light and the dark coming
in like
it makes sense lore wise and it's like
when beyond light gets here
maybe the actual story within prophecy
almost like has to change a little bit
that's kind of what i'm wondering too
and as you said he's sitting in the
tower it's like
what if he's not sitting in the tower in
the fall yeah technically he should
right yeah
i mean he's at least flying out there
for a little while to meet him i don't
know if he comes back but
it's a good question what you're
thinking what'd you do for terry
no i mean i always thought it had
something to do
with the lore and how they were going to
implement that going forward because
it's like at this point they're pulling
in many different directions with all
these characters like we don't know
where they're going to be situated at
when a new dlc comes out
right the fact that you launch it from
the tower
but you end up on drifter ship is like i
always thought it was funny
i was like okay well whatever but um i
think
they just want to centralize everything
a little more you know but my hope is
always the fact that they built they're
secretly putting this into a new engine
and that's what i
hope what's the shout out to the team
that's what i'm hoping
i'm hoping that we get a modification of
this engine and that's what they're
doing but
especially now since it's the fact that
everything
a lot of the stuff is being put into the
vault so it'll be a little i mean i
don't know development on it but you
wouldn't seem like it's a little bit
easier to do that since we're removing
so much stuff
right and they're not trying to port the
whole entire game over to something
different
but i do think it's just lore
implications and stuff but yeah secretly
i'm like
can this be a little bit better and i've
been and looking at the trailer and
stuff
it seems like a lot of stuff is moving a
lot more fluid i mean we're looking at a
uh we're looking at a trailer versus
playing it so you'll never know until
you actually
get a chance to play the content to see
how it feels and
interacts with you but it seems like
they're doing a little bit
of stuff different from what we usually
see when it comes to the trailer they
put out for
beyond light yeah yeah they got they got
a lot of promo to do too you know so we
still got a lot of promo run as we as we
get closer
um yeah it's probably like some type of
lower reason as to why this thing
is going to do what it's going to do but
you know the fact that it is coming back
because it would be
very sad if this thing was like going
away we don't get it back no more this
is literally one of the best pieces of
content
they've done in some time so you know i
got confidence in them i'm just very
i'm very curious to see how the content
volt
gets implemented how that whole thing
works you know what i'm saying
obviously we're getting the cosmic drone
back that's a huge deal
that's got to be i don't think it's
going to be just a one-to-one i think
we're going to get
a lot of filler in that that that play
space it's like we're not
going to just remember everybody we're
not getting the full thing in season 12.
right yeah it's coming out in pieces
some yeah
just to set like set expectations like
cosmodrome when it starts is
mostly for the new leg experience and
then they say 13 they're gonna fill that
out hopefully for story reasons is the
goal yeah
absolutely absolutely so no dungeon
that's my worry is that we got the
dungeon now and i don't get a dungeon in
year four
or and then when it comes back i've
already kind of done it but in fairness
like i feel like
i mean it's nice to see your engineering
is kind of greedy together
i've always felt that like i i'm i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna say no
no when they offer it you know but it's
like i always felt like they always
should have done i always thought the
dungeons should have probably been
during the season when stuff is light
like because the raid is its own thing
like the raid is a big thing you start
off the season world first
i always felt it's a lot to throw both
at once when shadow keep did it i was
like yo that's that's
you know okay that's a lot and this was
like seven hours after the season i was
like all right that's a little quick
yeah so like for me i'm like yeah that
was quick too you know
but it's like for me i like that the
dungeon get thrown into
that you know seasonal model so that
that has a little bit more beef to it
because
now it made our rivals feel beefy like
we had something really to do
you know what i'm saying like end
game-wise that we didn't expect so
that's just me
yeah the only thing i think when it
comes to that is the fact that
um for last wish um for forsaken
the only reason we didn't get the
dungeon day one is because of the
um recycle the three wreaths of the
curse so we got it on the third week
but it was always there it just wasn't
dope
yeah i like how they did that i like how
they did it so it was basically time
gated but it was there
day one and we just had to wait for the
curse to play itself out
um for shadow key it was there
literally there in the first week and
the thing that works probably the next
dlc when it comes to a dungeon
and stuff is the fact that yeah we just
got one
the chance we're not going to get one
with the dlc drops right
it's going to be a raid but then they're
bringing voted glass back
yeah and when they're bringing voter
glass back and if they're not bringing
it back
they're probably not going to bring back
that same season or later in that season
they're going to bring it back in season
13
and if they bring it in season 13 or 14
how much further does that push out a
new dungeon
that's a good question i mean for me i
think it's a good problem to have
because
it is a great question yeah yeah the the
way i like it is because let's be real
each you know i don't want to have them
seasoned at the drifter moments
you know what i'm saying i like
a lot i get it i mean i didn't mind
prime but i just felt
when the season is forced between this
back and forth to activity depending on
the other activity
it was just i mean that also wasn't the
best cycle of things
those could have been a bit more
independent for sure and then
outside all right put it this way if
that would have been that and then they
would have a dungeon
on top of that you can sell me on that
you know i think for me it was just like
i like that we got this problem right
because now
when are we going to throw in vaulted
glass vaulted glass could go in anything
i'm betting my money on season 14. you
got your money for tea
summer well spring season whatever
yeah main reason
the last so season 15 will lead into
witch queen
same way rivals is leading into beyond
light which is
crazy that we're getting closer towards
savithoon we've got
season 13 which is after beyond light we
know is the cosmodrome getting fleshed
out
more and potentially some story there
with like cosmodrome something on earth
and edz and stuff of that nature
the weakest season always is the spring
drifter whether you like it or not it's
still like not everybody's favorite
unworthy and then usually that lull in
the spring
so what is the one thing that will
appease all the hardcore people yeah
i would give them vaulted blasts
light season but vaulted glasses there
yeah these old content they just bring
the assets up yeah whatever
yeah polish them off i'm still curious
how they do that though is it going to
be like
just a piece how are we getting to the
volatile glass
because the opening is the patrol space
of venus
that's a good point theoretically you'd
still have the skybox of venus
why how do we get to venus if it's not
on the map
is it are we teleported there how much
can you see is it like walled off it is
visibly
from because you could literally just
like here's the opening you go drive
either direction from it
like i want to know how they limit that
thing too i want to know how they
integrate it like forte because my thing
is
is it like a moment of triumph moment
well remember what we did
or is it a moment like how is it the
effects of doing crazy stuff we gotta go
back in time and relive some
like how are they going to implement it
into the narrative of the game
or is it just like a remember the time
moment
moment of truth you know what i'm saying
like how it what you think
uh i think it depends on how this whole
um
nine situation plays out i think the
nine is gonna have a lot to do with
with a lot of the things that's gonna
happen in the uh in the future with
destiny
the fact that they took a whole dlc and
literally base or a whole dungeon and
based it around that
and then to build up with the um story
between
um the drifter and the nine all that
stuff's going to come to a head at a
certain point
and i think you're going to become an
ambassador for tonight and there's gonna
be things that you're gonna be doing i
think
the nine is basically taking the place
of callus at this point
and you're gonna be and you're gonna be
using the nine is gonna be using you to
go back and doing things and that's how
i think you're gonna be able to access
the vote on that photograph
some more almost like time or
dimensional travel to get back to a
point when that was
how are you going to get yeah how are
you going to get there i mean because i
was thinking the same thing but
the fact that they're putting these
threads with the nine in there the nine
could pretty much do
for what we see they could pretty much
put you wherever they want to put you
in any type of dimension so even knowing
the vaulted glass may not be on the
plane that we are on now
we can end up there in some alternate
reality where we actually had to
maybe bring something back from the
floating glass or something like that
um for me it always comes back to how
not really how they're going to
implement how we're going to get there
how how are we going to interact with it
and what are we going to get from get
from it
that's the thing you know what's the
rewards are going to be key too
the reward's going to be huge yeah yeah
because there's a lot of um
as much as i give that that raid crap
as much as i get that ray crap say it
louder
the the weapons in that raid are
undeniable my man
they're undeniable they are they are
they are the cream of the crop when it
came to d1
i was like unfortunately vision of
confluence wouldn't be sitting too
pretty in this current meta
no it wouldn't be yeah they have to fix
they would have to fix that
fate bringer wouldn't feel pretty good
i'm sure for everybody they'd love that
uh there's something that the game would
just be a regular audit but see there's
a thing about vault weapons and they had
to do something
really drastic to change it up because
we have weapons now that are just as
good as the weapons that we're in there
yeah so how do they change it up and
then on top of that you know they don't
really have the elemental capacity like
they had before and that was one of the
biggest things that those weapons had of
right a lord
yeah yeah what did they do to change
that they doing that yeah i think they
are
anti-elemental primaries they are yeah
and are they going to bring vex back
because you can't have voted glass
without a vet it's like some ethnic last
oh yes effects gotta come back that's
gonna come back like instant nerf gun
they're not gonna let that break the
game but i was like what it is those are
some iconic pieces and that's one thing
i forget they were talking about
hawkmoon
i don't know if it was guardian royale
or here or where i talked about it
somebody's like hawkmoon's gonna come
back and they mentioned that and i was
like
but it's not gonna have luck in the
chamber so i'm like why is it even
called that
because that was the whole point like i
know like playstation got to enjoy xbox
never had the true like luck of the
chamber
so it has a different feel i'm not
arguing i'm just saying
when it was what it's memorable for when
i played it even datto's had the
question more than i ever will
hawkmoon is one of those things like so
you take this the way hawkmoon felt good
was that moment like it was a good
feeling hand cannon but it was that
moment you get the like
special one you're like holy and you
hear the ting and like if you get it all
the stack you get those
rarely holy crap single shot kills like
that's what made it unique otherwise it
was just a
good feeling hand cannon didn't have any
major stellar moments like
how are you gonna make that thing
different but again turn how are you
gonna take
the fate bringers i can't even remember
the auto rifle from in there was like a
900 rpm that you'd use to burn down like
anything
epilogue yep so i mean there were
certain ones in there like now you just
take
you know it's an it's like a non-hunger
but just turned into a 900 rpm that's
all that's going to be
so it's like as you said how are you
going to take and this is a bigger
question again i think when hopefully
we'll see more when they get into it in
the fall
what are they going to do for in-game
rewards to make them special because
we're talking about like
we were talking about pitt of heresy
somebody in the chat it's like i love
zolamek armor we've said that here
before like of course womack armor
or raids that have raid weapons that
have either another perk or
you know something to set these apart
and actual raid perks would be a thing
too
yeah all of these things if you bring it
back
i think trials has issues that's why it
came back and didn't do so hot
if the rewards would have been right
cheaters wouldn't have been there it
could have done well but if you bring
back
the like the rose gold glasses on vault
of glass
vault can be good and it is it's still
like one of the raids everybody ranks it
pretty high generally
not always but it's still one of those
that like has a good experience they've
done
so much since then yeah absolutely if
they don't like
evolve both the rewards a little bit
because they'll have champions in there
but the rewards playing jane the way it
was
come on now you know i know i know
they're gonna say like champions but
like
i want them to take like the motivation
of hey we need to evolve vault of glass
to bring it into destiny 2 i'm hoping
that absolutely takes
all the other end game absolutely gonna
happen absolutely
i mean they they've already shown that
they they can do that
i have no worry in that regard those
weapons
will not only get updated or some type
of
perk added to it to um influence
basically where d2 is now
but more important i want to get back to
your other question which was hawkmoon
i feel y'all you know see for me my
perspective is different i never had it
in its original form i i i know
i know nothing of that life say the
magic bullet like
but i will give them credit you know
let's be honest and i'm the first to be
guilty of this y'all
remember when they said they was
bringing throwing back and i was like oh
no
fam you know what i said like dawn was
scary
storm was scary and i was just like i
don't know and let's be real like
they brought it back decent they added
that different mechanic with the orb and
the thing and the pickup and stuff like
that is it the original thorn in its
original form no
but but it still has the damage over
time too it's yeah
it still has damage over time to it so
their their words where they're going to
re
rework it there's going to be a
different mechanic what i'm basically
saying is gonna be a different mechanic
that we just gotta see
what it's gonna be but i do feel for
guys like darto who
loved that gun in the essence of what
the gun was i i get that
if you call it something else yeah well
the fact that they said that it's not
gonna be a damage
um thing that they actually that affects
the gun is where
i'm like why are we bringing back
hawkmoon yeah i was like yeah the arts
pretty but make a new gun
yeah funny no but like that's that
hawkmoon is hawkmoon for reason
and it wasn't what it was that's not
happening
one bullet killing gun ain't happening
a while ago i was like and that's fine
but i was like leave it in the past
don't bring it back if you're gonna make
it a different gun
make a different gun don't make a
different gun
but slap an old game on it that's kind
of where it falls apart for me is
if it's like oh it gets like you know
you get this thing to proc where
reload speed is almost instant or fire
rate goes up or so i don't know what
it's going to do
mm-hmm or you get luck in the chamber
but can no land beyond on pc would be
broken oh god i didn't even think about
that oh yeah that's ridiculous
but there's certain guns that like it is
what it is for a specific reason
and if you take that intrinsic piece of
it away
why are you calling it that weapon in
the first place it would be like
thunderlord
coming back into destiny 3 if that ever
exists
and not having like the lightning rounds
that come with it because then it's just
an arc machine gun
it's something that's deep into it
they've done it
they've done this already where they've
brought guns back and they don't operate
exactly in the way that they operated in
d1
we have some examples you know what i'm
saying it to me it's like
like what's the one that's that far off
yeah
thorn still has damage over time the orb
is different
the way it shoots it's still a
projectile thing you've still got the
damage over time
it's not like you got rid of the dot you
didn't get rid of the damage attack that
is still there that's an intrinsic piece
of it
the damage you have picked up and do
this whole
synergistic thing that didn't even exist
like
but the orb makes the orb improves it
like it's an evolution on it but it
doesn't change the intrinsic nature of
how it works
so why can't they just make an evolution
of of this because they
said they're not doing the damage thing
well that's why what else they're going
to do before we
ain't complaining let's see
what it is first before we say
well let's just see like what you're
going in yo i don't even want
can we see what something else is can we
just see what it is
listen liz i need to get off your horse
for a second sir oh my god
we need you to get off your horse
i'm with you man i i'm also one of those
people that didn't get
a chance to experience hawkmoon at its
greatest being on xbox
but they are literally taking the thing
that made that weapon
that weapon and they're saying we're not
getting in we never got that weapon
either
but but guess what but listen listen
they're taking
luck in the chamber away all together
you're not getting you're not getting
the
you're not getting luck in the chamber
you're not getting holding aces
so you're getting both those perks are
the two main perks on that weapon don't
even exist
in destiny 2. right so the fact that
they said we're not
improving the gun in that matter and
it's not going to be a damage
type what are is the weapon going to be
so there's nothing else that weapon
could do to be exciting so just because
it should just be something else it can
be any other hand cannon that does any
other thing but
basically so let me let me be clear let
me be clear so basically what y'all
saying
unless the gun comes back and it's
original for any old exotic
should not come back unless it's exactly
the way
it was made no literally that is
so you so you don't so you want to
change do you want to change you can't
have a change which one is no use
does it have to come back in it's
original form or not
that's what it is this is not no you're
like
drawing a line in the sand that's not
there we're saying like things can
change
all of that if they were like hey look
in the chamber
maybe look in the chamber was like one
in every three bullets so you only have
one bullet per clip or there's less of a
damage buffer any of those changes
can all be a variation on what makes
hawkmoon hawkmoon
those are all changes that would still
keep hawkmoon having luck in the chamber
having it having holding aces still
being a possibility of keeping
what makes hawkmoon hawkmoon
right right so changes are fine the
evolution we're literally saying thorn
is fine
thorin has changed it got an evolution
so now you got to be a little more
active to pick it up to get the boost
but still got to damage
this particular not the luck in the
chamber change that is what makes the
that is the only thing that makes that
weapon different
otherwise it is a hand cannon it is a
legendary
it is a legendary hand cannon without
luck in the chamber and
holding aces that is what makes that
weapon exotic and they're literally
said there will be no damage changes
that's all that weapon did
if those are gone it's a legendary and
that is specifically what made
there's no you know do you know what
hawkmoon's going to do when it comes
when it drops
of course
all i'm saying is let's just see what
the change is
before you complain that's all i'm
saying you're bitching about something
you don't know
that's what i'm saying that you don't
even know what the new thing is going to
do but you oh i don't want it because
it ain't doing what it did in
eighty-five that's just [ __ ] there's
already a weapon
in destiny 2 that's basically what a
hawkmoon
looks like
you want to give us an example can you
tell me because
y'all tell me what the new intrinsic
you're on your high horse let me ask you
a question let me ask you a question
you're not being fair to the developer
i'm just saying let's just be fair
you're so emotional
about what it was let's just see what it
could be
let me ask you something okay look
you tell me what was what was what was
the allure
of hawkmoon what was it we've already
discussed this what the just answer the
question what was this we've already
discussed what is
luck in the chamber the magic bullet the
combination that one particular bullet
could have both of these perks to do an
instant kill we get that we've
it's not about just the instant kill
it's the fact that that weapon
literally could to tap yes consistently
at least once every magazine at least
naturally twice magazine we
know this but it's okay but listen
without that bonus
that weapon is basically an offstringer
okay
what is it so okay so so
so the fact that okay so you're
basically saying you're okay with
hawkmoon
at the base level being an offstringer
so wait let that let me stop you this
way you're wrong so you're acting like
just because that perk is not there
there are no other perks or new perks
that they can add to the gun
to make the gun interesting
but it's not that gun anymore we know
intrinsically what is
but the damage over time is still the
same the projectile is the same
it's not as effective as it was when you
have thought you can use
a weapon you could bring back okay no no
okay so hold on
hold on you could do hawk moon
and maybe luck in the chamber only adds
fifty percent damage and you can't two
tap but it gives you
that would be an evolution or a change
in the weapon
if you gave me thorn and the dot was
gone
damage over time was gone that wouldn't
be thorn anymore is what we're saying
because that is the idea it's that type
of bullet for its functionality
if you brought back a hand cannon that
did other things
call it a different weapon that's what
we're saying about hawkmoon is the idea
with hawkmoon is you bring back a weapon
that does
i understand that how do you not get
that if you bring us a hand because i
just don't understand that we are not
even
willing to see what the new perk is i
just don't think it should be hawkmoon
call it another thing it's just like
something else you can't even don't look
the same
call it something else get your hand off
this gun
that's what just it's just the most
wildest thing i've ever heard like we're
not even willing to see
it's just interesting to me it's very
interesting to me that hawkmoon fans
are like what's you know what's so funny
why y'all hypocritical
because they literally did that to the
xbox guys the xbox guys never had hot
moon in its appearance for him
and nobody yeah but they didn't take
they
literally didn't never get they made
sure
that you could never get the combination
on the next one will still hit you can
still two tap with it
that's all that gun had you got either
one tap if you got the perfect roll of
everything stacked together
or you could two-tap if you had the
bullet in a second and that's
that's literally the whole gun that's
all the game you did
and the funny thing is if you and dado
the biggest proponent of that gun he
even said in this video
he only got that to proc once or twice
and all the kills he had on hawkmoon to
get the kill
one time in one shot twice in that one
so the jungle was never about just the
one bullet kill it was just the fact
that uh you had the opportunity
to to tap somebody did it every day
let me ask you 150. so with this logic
and i'll leave this alone because
clearly it's going on too long um with
this logic
okay i just want to make sure if they
decided
to bring back icebreaker with
your guys logic they cannot bring it
back
unless regeneration bullets happen for
this sniper correct
don't bring back icebreaker don't
breathe so if they make now
now here's my counter we do understand
that having a gun that does
systematically
break the sandbox by regenerating birds
is
not so much a
let me finish let me finish that i'll
let you get your balls off now
we do understand that having a two tap
or one tap hand cannon
is not balanced we do know this right
correct
okay that's all i'm saying thank you
that's all i wanted to say but why
did you got just about that
different hand cannon that does
something else it's not going to have
the same perks it's not going to be the
same
selfishness this is the epitome of
selfishness oh my god
i'm glad i got somebody else in this
podcast because i would be literally
throwing my desk
in the air i bring back the bring back
the sandbox breaking
no that's not what we're saying give us
give us a new hand cannon
don't call it hawkmoon that's all we're
saying if it's not going to function
like the old and that's
i i totally like we're never going to
just bring back
we're never going to get icebreaker
we're never going to get icebreaker as
we did
correct we all agree that should never
come back it breaks the game
so then we should never then we should
never get icebreaker ever again
because it stays in the past so it is if
they bring back an icebreaker that's
like
hey you get triple tap on icebreaker if
that's what we're saying if they brought
back icebreaker and it was like
maybe it was like four times the charm
was the perk on it
would you like that
i want to see what the new gun does i
don't like that they bring well that's
like if they bring back
uh gallo horn without wolf pack rounds
would you really want a gallon horn
without wolf pack rounds
what else could it do what if they add a
cool other little perk to it did that
means you just don't bring back gala
horn you make it you break something
else
i just don't subscribe to this don't
bring it back because it it um
because you're still like the exact
you're taking the essence of what that
weapon
is and making it something else
different weapon don't really skip
something else it's
not fair to the sandbox that is
currently in the game
thus it will be broken that's the thing
just call whatever
whatever hawkmoon's whatever the new
perkins understand
they're going to be the allure of the
lord so you're basically saying that
bungie's just bringing back hawkmoon to
get people excited for just
okay i get i understand that but
make a new exotic they've done that
we've got effigy we've got with a horse
keep going
that's all we just a new then make a new
example it's just
it's just selfishly you guys want it to
operate exactly the way it knows
i just wanted to have look that weapon
was look the first thing people thought
when that weapon was it now say oh my
god
luck in the chamber is gonna suck and
the fact that they said oh it's not
gonna have a damage boost that's
not how we're going to operate the
weapon when it comes back
then what is hawk move listen
we going in circles we're not gonna
we're not we're never gonna get uh a
medium here so i'm gonna call it really
not
i'm gonna call it i'm glad we're here
today so i don't feel crazy
no it's just like i said yeah your heart
is just bent to it i get it
you want it in its purest the most
purest form of sandbox i get it
i i've just i side with the developer
when it comes to
stuff that breaks the game and and i get
it you guys are asking for your guys
you guys are siding with purity of the
weapon we're just gonna have to disagree
that's
all i can't wait till this week because
we are ilp
hey you know what's funny don't let this
weapon be hot please let me
go get work don't let this weapon be
fire
and everybody's having fun with don't
let me catch what of you two and your
videos
having fun with this new weapon because
y'all gonna
get it i'm gonna be like 114
these dudes are like don't bring it back
and hold the hunter to the fire if this
weapon is hot and fun and everybody's
loving it because i'm coming for them
trust me i'm coming for them it doesn't
matter if it's fun
it has to be the magic to the intensity
of the weapon the integrity of the
weapon
don't let it be fine i will have no fun
from you or two with this weapon if it's
good
no i'm gonna have this day one i'm just
gonna say in a video that i don't know
why they call it hawkmoon yeah yeah
that's a lot no fun you want the essence
of the weapon
you want the magic bullets you want two
taps all
that so i don't want no other love for
this gun if it come back and it's
fire y'all gonna get this work
[Laughter]
i told you i'm not conversation episode
14 last word 140.
i i don't know i don't know what to do
now forte i don't know where to go
yes welcome welcome to the gift yeah
like there's there's no
getting through sometimes it's just like
if he's stuck
can't i can't get like just don't get
don't have no fun don't let me catch you
i have fun that's all
that's literally not the point that
is the point you said don't bring it
back why bring it back
why because you like you had fun with it
in its original state
so don't bring it back if it's not what
it what if it's right
it's
all we're all the guns can be we got
this the gun
is not listening to y'all bungie's
listening to me
that's the funny part budgie not
listening to y'all bungie's listening to
me on this
so i want to see let's just see how it
let's see how that
let's see i've had fun or not oh my god
well at least 14 i can uh empathize on
this one so anyways
uh we do have iron banner coming back
next week
it's like we can't even finish this damn
podcast now
because my mind is like blown away how
starch you're defending this man
i'm not defended i'm just telling y'all
what it is his shirts even like turned
over here all bunched up
do you see those guns come out man the
neck the muscles in the neck started
popping
i gotta accept change brother y'all
gotta accept change man
y'all fighting it it's happening that's
all i'm saying it's happening bro
oh my god i can sit there on the soapbox
all your life but they doing this
uh short little rap iron banners next
week the forward path and the fool's
remedy come back we got a hotfix coming
with a couple fixes
uh basically fixing a couple of the
nightfalls
raids are gonna be work like leviathan's
gonna be working properly for awards
couple other fixes as well other than
that
we just know the season is long and
that's kind of where we're at
uh salsa severos starts on the 11th not
the coming week we got one more week
i don't know why i even thought that was
coming this week because even when i
logged in
somebody on twitter was like anything
this week and i was like
nope yeah gotta slow down this week
nothing of note at least i saw that twab
and i was like
man this is well at least
it's lights they're filling those times
with those bungee deep dives
yeah i just i i like the fact that they
finally opened it up to be able to just
farm these raids like yeah i need to go
get taraba i need to get it
i decided i actually need to do that
it's not what i'm looking forward to but
i do need to farm that you know
honestly i'm not gonna lie as much as i
think last wish is
probably the best rate that they did in
d2
i crown of sorrow is something about the
fanatic pace because of the hive being
involved
yeah and i always like and that's one
thing i liked about um
dark blood well um
it was just how fast it oh there there's
hello guest appearance guess the first
thing
that's a destiny fan right there there
we go but um
the fact that um it's just super fast
paced
is what i like about it the most and i
just like the end
encounter with the boss it's just so
many moving parts and
uh shout out i figured who y'all had on
two weeks ago that does ray carries
oh zoey zoey yeah zoey and how she was
talking about like how that raid
people everybody has something to do
yeah i
love that aspect of that rage so i like
i
normally when i'm doing lfg i just look
for boss checkpoints but in that raid
i'll literally just start from the
beginning and do the whole
job i've still never done that right got
to do that right
we got to change that bro yeah
that's funny oh man well
talk about uh getting all hyped hot and
bothered and stuff and then coming down
off of that
it's not a show well it's not a show
let's forte here getting
triggering cognito everywhere it's not
wrong
so i finally get a chance to bring it to
the show instead of in the comment
section
i'm just glad you were here when it was
on my side because man
i would have been like pulling my hair
out
during this discussion if it was just me
versus him back and forth
we've been there we've been there on the
radar i i've seen it
he see it he sees how many weeks until
we find out we have like a hundred days
so
do the math like basically the new
season pass
yeah pretty much yeah that was crazy it
was like july 31st and i was thinking
but you got august september october i
was like we have three months and 10
days before we get i was like
that's a lot of time too a lot of time
that is a lot of time i mean
all we get festival lost expectations
about this much
uh we got solstice of heroes which will
be cool i'm actually looking forward to
seeing the armor design for solstice
yeah because that's usually one of the
coolest things for armor sets that we've
had in d2 because d1 armor still kills
it all but d2 salt like the solstice
armor
last season especially if they take it
to the next level has potential to be
cool
potentially more european aerial zone
hopefully with an evolution easy gotta
come back
easy was fun i will say when you had to
do it on all three characters to get
like the [ __ ]
dude yeah that was i hope they like i
hope they ease the grind a little bit
don't make it just because we have a
hundred days
that event still in like three weeks or
something yeah
what do you guys think about um because
we got braytech
the winter wolf the last two seasons for
rewards i'm hoping they give us
something different
for festivals because we got the winter
wolf the last two times
we need something else we need something
else yeah they gotta they gotta add like
some type of different reward
they had what was when they had the
avalanche machine gun avalanche was for
cooking right mm-hmm yeah uh you got the
valve
for crimson for crimson days the valbo
probably the best weapon they've given
in an event is the one that
tayden get which is the um the machine
gun yeah that was probably the only
i absolutely refused to do that
i wasn't
the um
i haven't used it since i got it but it
is a pretty cool weapon
that's like it is one of those that i've
thought about i was like would i use it
and i'm like
in theory maybe but also it's just a
spinning up piece
like because if i think about it i can
go 21 percent delete and then just pull
it it's like fire five five fire and
it's like
you gotta be spinning up so if it was
like sustained for a while like i'm
going to be here i'm going to be mowing
guys while you guys are
it has a purpose but we haven't had like
an encounter specifically that's like
i need to mow guys like 500 guys down i
need to mow down in this corner
while some other people do some other
stuff but i can do this all day long
like
it has a purpose but it's like i haven't
seen a good fit for it yet
yeah it's like for me i love it the
problem is
with xeno because dps a little faster
it can't really be it's f to me it's
good for people if you don't have xeno
if you you just don't have other weapons
then this is a good fallback one because
it does hit hard and i love
you love the shield you know what i'm
saying expect pvp is very underrated
it's just like i said again if you have
the top-tier stuff
then i couldn't find a place for it
that's it went in the vault
you know i said i just refused to do it
because of that event
yeah that was great i was like nope nope
and then we just came flush off the
event that they had us throwing balls at
the tower nope
nope really yeah how's that timing too
much not the best on that one
because that was that killed me i would
sit like i was telling kai again thing i
was like he was like you get it yet i
said
no i'm not throwing a ball at another
tower
and then i was like look and i was
looking at yvonne's i was
shout out to you man cause you was in
the stream you were he was you was you
was part of the
part of the culture of trying to get
that weapon for everybody and i was like
oh shout out to eban just getting that
weapon from me because i'm not doing it
i'm not throwing no more balls and no
towers i said not the fact that none of
this stuff counted when we were doing
this
for hundreds and hundreds of times
winter's life oh
yeah i'm not doing it i said i'll enjoy
the weapon thank you for and guess what
i haven't even used it don't feel bad
for that because i did the same you know
when i did the same thing
whatever that event that arbalest was in
i was like i ain't doing that
and then but literally the next season i
went to
as soon as the next thing started i went
to sir you was defeated and it got
overlooked
no and that's the same thing i'm
thinking about um about
about that whatever that machine that it
is that i ain't got because
they're apparent they're apparent that's
the deal yeah i literally want to talk
about it because i'm like
i look at people now i won't lie i see
somebody kill me with that's like oh man
that's cool but then i was like
no no it's not no it's not don't don't
allow yourself to think it's cool
nope i'm good it's not cool you're good
dude just as soon as the new season
start go right over
go right over this earth use that faded
you're good to go well the biggest thing
for me is trying to find a way to
replace my
beloved i still haven't replaced it yet
i have to find a weapon to replace
that sniper what is
yep yeah what i'm saying it's energy
right yeah it's energy
i mean there's a bunch of energy weapons
but it's like that weapon
is like the perfect balance of
of a sniper it's like what's the highest
highest aim assist you can get on one
perfect scope um handling is
like beyond perfect and once you get the
the right roads i'm like i got quick um
snapshot quick draw on mines
is it aggressive frame oh adaptive oh
it's adapted all right so it's right in
the middle okay
i get a lap that joint is loved like
it's oh
dude i get killed by that all the time i
don't i don't
know what i'm gonna do because i haven't
even tried to replace it yet so
but i gotta i got three i guess i got
three months to do it
yeah and that's the thing it's like
right now you don't have to rush
anything
you got plenty time to grind for god
rules like nog hungers or anything else
you got time
and hopefully just like take the time to
try and balance out the rest of the
season so you don't like
don't burn out on something so much like
there's a lot of good stuff to play
between now and then hopefully so if you
need a little break take it because you
do actually have a lot of time which is
good yeah absolutely
we have a ton of time shout out to um
microsoft for giving a game
yeah that's gonna be big huge
yeah that microsoft number is about to
go up because you just
game past being like oh just go ahead
and log in yeah
yeah they'll definitely be higher than
stadia
if i had to cancel that subscription
know aries in the chat
yeah well i might have to cancel that
man i can't see a way
to justify keeping it that was the the
only thing holding me was
that whole environment being
non-cheating
but trials gonna have to go down or
that's on xbox but the fact that it was
gonna be 60 frames per second because
that's the one thing that we remember
kyle when we were doing it it was like
yeah this looks horrible the field of
view is terrible but it's 60 frames per
second
on stadium 60 and now we ain't got to
deal with input lag
yeah with the input lag so it's like
yeah so
shout out to them for that man i think
there's um i think there's a little bit
more to that story too when it comes to
i think this is just the beginning
honestly i think so too i think so
i think literally for them to do a deal
like that in this initial stage they
they took a bag up front already
and for them to put the to me which made
the deal over the top is putting the
beyond light in there because
if you put beyond light in there that's
a that's a next level most would have
just made it free to play and that would
have been fine
that's this is not your typical typical
marketing kind of a deal
so yeah i've heard rumblings you know um
we'll see we'll see what happens but i
definitely think there is
there may be something more we'll we'll
see but for those who are worried
destiny would if anything that happened
destiny wouldn't be affected it would
destiny would still continue to operate
in the manner it it would operate so
yeah
within console family cross play yes
and then they're shooting for 2021 or
whenever it launches now
due to delays uh they're shooting for
yeah
full cross-play everywhere which will be
we talked about you know maybe opt-in
for mouse and keyboard verse controller
stuff like that but
right um honestly for even pve
activities and stuff like that
matchmaking
all that type of stuff should be should
be nice i think that should be day
one i don't even understand why they
don't do that earlier it's like i can
understand the pvp side of it but for
pve
that should just be open yep oh yeah
straight up
there's no reason you would like oh no
somebody on mouse and keyboard is
helping with the strike
okay yeah exactly i don't see the
problem yeah like that should be
a pvp opt-in like some type of
choice i guess to see how it goes i
think the issue
okay no you're gonna say enough no i
said it's not it's actually not as bad
as people think because i play
i do play keyboard and mouse on pc but i
play
more controller just so i can stay at
practice and going back and forth
between the two
but um you can dominate because people
keep forgetting that destiny is
inherently a console game
and you can dominate on pc with a
controller
yeah absolutely it's not it's not hard
so i'm really not worried about even the
people i mean as much
for the basically for everybody else i
just say just kind of
make it opt-in for pvp for console but
if i was in a mixed lobby that wouldn't
buy me one bit and i would tell people i
do you if you good
you you'll be all right yeah you know
yeah yeah man
like i said i think a lot of it is
inherently with the tiger engine
why these decisions are being made i
think because the way
they've done a lot of these tech um
developer meetings i think gdc and stuff
like that when they were talking about
it
the way they do their instances and in
the whole peer-to-peer
it's just weird overlapping i don't want
to say mess because i'm not a developer
but
i'm saying it's like this weird
overlapping way it's designed and
unfortunately that's why we're not
getting dedicated servers
it literally comes down to the way this
thing design but the hope is
that if this thing if they can somehow i
don't know if it's possible
evolve the tiger over you know during
the course of a life cycle of the game
we know there's not going to be a three
and at least they're not saying a number
right now
but if they can somehow during that
course upgrade the
engine just it would be cool to see what
the possibilities could do you know
saying
how far they can expand it because
that's something they need to do like
the whole whether whether it be the
cross play whether it be like i said
what they're going to do long term for
cheating
there's still a lot they got to figure
out so we'll see man i don't envy them
but i think at some point like he was
saying i would love still loving part
three
you know but we'll see yeah for sure on
both
excuse me um that's most of what we got
for this weekend
obviously the twab was very light and it
seems like it's just
we got time and yeah we got a lot of
time
we do got a lot of time so if you're
like hey i need a little break from this
something else is coming out tempting me
you got three months plus you got you
got time to go play a couple different
games i'm sitting here looking at ghosts
sitting in act two and i'm over here
like horizon xerodon comes out in
literally a week and i'm like
rap i don't have enough time that's what
i'm worried about
it's a i think between the two games and
then what november
10th november is going to be stupid you
got some job
that's so stupid that timing is so crazy
you got some time i mean we know that
the those events gonna be a little
grindy
you know we know that you know most
likely they're gonna make us do them
strikes do the easy and do that stuff
but um you know once once you're banging
out and then multiple character guys you
should have that done pretty fast
then it's back to like getting just play
games play your games
we know what it is november's gonna come
we give them the time that they need
and then uh we'll be right back in the
mix
well i think we probably screamed at
each other enough for a little bit there
probably need to
probably need to wrap this thing up we
need some social discipline
yeah we definitely need some type of
distancing different different uh
discord servers for a little while guys
we got
we got to go in timeout cognito's got to
go in the timeout channel so i gonna go
to tabachi
now honestly uh forte it's been
fantastic to have your man
thank you very much for joining us big
friend of the show
and thank you very much for just like
being a good piece of this community
definitely being here to help be a good
part of it a positive influence in
everything that you do so
thank you and this is kind of floor is
yours man for anything you want to tell
them what you got coming up anything you
got we're working on
where they can find you where they can
watch you all that stuff man it is all
yours
yeah man um first of all i
this was like a dream being over here
with you guys i always tell kai
i even look when i was looking up the
video with slo-mo i was like how long
has been since
i said it was a year ago when slo-mo was
on here and then that video cog was like
oh yeah
forte we go get you in here soon a year
later
i was like okay he must he ain't
he he finally held up to his bargain so
that was cool but uh no man you guys are
amazing i love what you guys do
you guys are uh a really big part of
this community even knowing you guys
feel like
you know you don't get as much love as
you think you should because i think you
guys deserve
way more than what you actually get um
just know that the people that
actually do watch and support you
actually do care and want you guys to be
as best as you can be and i'll be there
to root you on at fifty thousand when
you hit it ebatis so
thank you guys he's close he's close
he's
800 away look i know we fought today and
i hate him today
but please subscribe to him because he's
awesome
right exactly you know so i'm gonna even
do even better job of making sure that i
um push out that content to make sure
that you know
everybody knows who imanis is cause
facts i feel like you need to be
even bigger than you are absolutely but
for myself it's gaming forte everywhere
youtube and twitter two channels um i
got my
basically xboxing playstation channel
gaming forte that's the main channel
my love of consoles will never die and
the community that i have fostered with
the people like cognito and everybody to
help me build it is
something that i truly uh appreciate so
that's where
most of the content is i literally just
did start
a destiny one all over again because it
just doesn't fit with the main channel
anymore
and i always just wanted to find a niche
for it and the niche is well when i play
destiny on pc i don't see too many
people talking about the ultra wide
aspect of the game
playing in a playing on the ultra right
monitor i have a 34
inch one it's a complete game changer
yes on top of the field of view that you
can play at
the things that you can see and do in
that environment
are amazing and it doesn't just stem
just from destiny it's any game you play
so i'm literally going to build my
destiny content basically around the
ultra wide field of view and let people
know like the things you can do
and that basically came from a video i
did about
two years ago when destiny came out and
i said on pc
and i was like destiny and ultra wide
and that video did like 10 000 views
just because it was a ultra wide video
and i was like huh
they always say get a niche and you know
destiny the one thing about destiny is
it's a lot of people making videos on it
and um
it's hard to try to fit in somewhere so
that's where i want to fit my niche in
so um
if you're uh interested in that it's
going to be called ultra wide forte
gotta keep that
exclusive ultra ultra wide forte um
channels already made videos gonna be
going up on that in the next
week or so um so i can get back to that
love of destiny because
i love making content and if you guys
make videos and stuff on destiny
and need help with um editing things
just reach out to me man i'm always
there to help with that too
but outside of that man i'm here in the
channel just to help you guys
and support you two wonderful people in
the channels that you guys have
appreciate you brother yeah first of all
shout out to forte because um
i said long overdue one of the most
passionate
destiny content creators i mean man like
we took
listen discussions that go down here
this goes down like
regularly it's real like it's just
passion y'all you gotta understand we
all brothers we
we love this game and one thing about
him he is a staunch
defender of destiny and besides the
defendant destiny he really supports the
community so
whoever is a content creator whoever
who's out there putting the work in is
putting the grind
you can always catch forte either
supporting
all throughout you know what i'm saying
whether showing up or just just being
there
for the community so definitely
ambassador please support her please
represent his channel you know what i'm
saying he's doing big things
and it's good to see that he's branching
out doing the ultra wide joint you know
what i'm saying so that's gonna be good
i'm
gonna check this out by the way i can
only imagine that he's so jealous yeah
man
this is this guy is really a great great
player dusty so salute to him we had to
do this get it going you know what i'm
saying
absolutely yeah man absolutely always
love always love somebody
so yes salty man you missed the whole
thing
wrapping up right now
yeah you'll you'll find it good i'm
going to use it there will be a
there will be a clip going up oh yeah i
already know what the clip's gonna be
i'm waiting for the biased nature of
that clip i might might have to dig up
my own clip on the other side
i gotta be vice you know i keep your
feet oh you already know
i i i'm real quick to like go through a
video and clip out what i want and post
posted on youtube
and saying look at god being a complete
nut head right now he's going to try to
get us right now
the clips going down but oh judges
saying look man it's going to be fun
yeah for me you already know outlaw
incognito
on twitter i love podcasts on youtube
all that good stuff every sunday is the
lord's day
1pm no actually 11 special time 11
a.m this sunday only for this sunday
we are accommodating the great benji
sales so we're gonna have some market
data analysts going in we're gonna break
down these sales we're gonna break down
what's going on in the industry we've
got
a lot of uh pc titles really doing well
right now shout out to grounded a lot of
other stuff
kind of forte for making slow-mo
playground it cuz that was hilarious
absolutely hilarious stream
that was a part of so salute the forte
for that but uh yeah we're gonna be
talking about that a lot of industry
trends maybe a little bit
infinite and what's going on with uh
playstation so check that out and also
last but not least
please lords of gaming dot net i
appreciate the support we're doing a
little well with that
and king of statues my brother king
david with the again if you're into the
marvel the dc stuff
please salute him he has his home
playlist up on the channel and again
salute to my man for take eat what you
got going on
uh for me yeah uh i mean of course over
the usual stuff between stream and ghost
and then
working on different content for you
guys in this right now so just kind of
going back and forth
debating on just yeah kind of working on
the prophecy guide potentially with like
non-meta setup because
i did a meta but you know potentially a
non-meta attempt to see how that goes
somebody threw the stupid idea in my
mind of potentially doing back to back
to back flawless dungeons
oh i have no idea when that may happen
but i got a hundred days to figure that
one out that sounds
stupid but with the practice with aries
yesterday it seems like
it wouldn't be the quickest thing in the
world but it might be doable so maybe
if you beat one and die on the second
start over all three dungeons have to be
flawless
back to back to back with no like
no break besides the bathroom it's like
you go to orbit go in the stream
you go to the next deck and then you go
to orbit and you go to the next one
that's right
we're gonna stream this sir oh whenever
it happens yeah it'll be a terrifying
thing to consider i gotta start i gotta
start practicing them let's just say
that i gotta practice sometimes i'll
make a
i will make a commitment right now sir
the moment you do that i will donate 10
subs to your channel
yes let me know whatever i'll matt and
i'll make that
change to your channel the moment that
happens that's crazy wow
i was like oh i was like somebody said
glad did it and i was just like i've
done them all separate
now to do them back to back to back
because like i don't know it's turning
into esoteric on me man
yeah you always know what's your
esoterical esoteric would do what i do
with an eye patch and a hand type behind
his back
like no it's like i'm no esoteric
another level from pretty much all of us
but it seems like something fun because
there are three
i don't know might might work on that
one so we got some time but that's
that's like
oh yeah that's a stretch challenge
that's a stretch challenge
um don't expect it tomorrow or anything
by any means
already listed it's thinking about that
amazing wait what is the
home of the violence of the building it
was going so good
okay we just wrap it up yep
uh but yeah for me just uh stupid dumb
stuff like that for a little while on
twitch
uh guides for you guys working on
whether it's builds or anything else or
anything just to help you guys
into the fall and just kind of staying
in tune with any news that we get on
this game
is the big key and obviously yeah
watching the big xbox and playstation
reveals as we get into the fall so
lots to look forward to can't wait to
see what all this brings we're in we're
in what i would call a little bit of a
quiet time
depending on what you're paying
attention to but it doesn't feel like
we're ever too far away from something
fun coming up so
absolutely right well guys this has been
fantastic forte again thank you sir as i
said pleasure to have you glad we
finally made it work
long overdue chat you guys have all been
fantastic and some of you guys just
grabbed the popcorn and watched the show
so it has been uh entertaining i'm
i'm kind of worried about what clips
cognitos is going to post just know if
you see a kind of i'm
going to be if you see clips on iron
lord's podcast that is definitely
him posting i might have to reply we'll
see
about the biased clip nature
i'm calling it now but anyways for
today it is july 31st thank you guys uh
episode 114 this has been a fantastic
one and for all of us here
our guest cognito and myself
it has been the last word